I SEE S.
SENATE ALL HERE. LET'S CALL
THIS. HEARING TO ORDER. ARE WE
ARE NOT GONNA BE TELEVISED
TODAY TURNS OUT WE'RE JUST NOT
AS IMPORTANT AS THE- SENATE
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE- THERE WE
ARE YEAH IT IN RESPONSE TO THE
MURDER THE PANDEMIC AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN HERE
TO SOCIAL DISTANCING A FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO YOUR NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THE PUBLIC INTO USED. TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS TO ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS
WE HAVE ADMITTED TO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO THE HEARING ROOM
TO THE SENATE SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WE WILL
BE USING A TELECONFERENCE OF IS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT WISH
TO TESTIFY. TODAY FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE TODAY'S. PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE THREE
THAT'S 877-692-8953 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN ZERO FIVE
SIX NINE ZERO NINE AT SEVEN
ZERO FIVE. SIX NINE ZERO NINE
AT THE ACCESS CODE. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE COULD TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE AND OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
WHEN WE MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY MY THE
MODERATOR. TO DIAL ONE THEN IF
ZERO FOUR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION PRESSES ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO SEND THESE TO A
LINE NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A
SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT
IN THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR
TO CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT
THAT TIME WILL BE ON MUTE AND
YOU ARE NOW WILL THEN BE READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE IN ORDER TO FOR US
TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY DEVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OF THE PHONE IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
WE'RE GONNA MAINTAIN DECORUM WE
ALSO- I JUST KIND OF ASK
FUHRMAN'S PATIENTS AS THEIR
LACK TIME SOCIO TECHNOLOGY SO.
WHY DON'T WE GO AHEAD AND
ESTABLISH A QUORUM WE'VE GOT
SIX BILLS TODAY ON TODAY'S
AGENDA ONE OF THEM. IS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. THE
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
TO SOUTH KOREA. ALLEN HERE
BATES DOLLY GONZALEZ. SKINNER
STERN MY CASCADE HERE OKAY WE
HAVE A QUORUM I SEE THAT OUR
FIRST PRESENTER FIRST AUTHOR IS
HERE- WE ACTUALLY HAVE IT'S A
THERE'S A JOINT AUTHORSHIP BY I
SEE- SO WE'VE GOT A SPECIAL
MEMBERS TANG AND IRWIN HERE TO
PRESENT. AB. FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT. AND YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
READING. THANK YOU MISTER LET
ME JUST- THE FIRST THANK YOU IN
YOUR COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS WERE
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE CLARIFYING
COMMITMENTS PROPOSED BY THE
COMMITTEE ON PAGE THIRTEEN OF
THE ANALYSIS BY IT BEFORE
SEVENTY EIGHT ESTABLISHES A
TIME FRAME FOR THERMOFORM FOOD
PACKAGING MANUFACTURERS TO USE.
MINIMUM RECYCLED CONTENT IN THE
PLASTIC CONTAINER STARTING WITH
10% AND 202420% 202730% BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE THE REFORM
FOOD CONTAINERS WE SEE THEM
EVERY DAY THERE THE CLAM SHELLS
THAT WHOLE STRAWBERRIES FOR
LEAFY GREENS OR TAKE OUT
CONTAINERS. APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED POUNDS IF THE REFORM
WASTE IS DISCARDED EACH YEAR IN
CALIFORNIA AND WHILE MANY OF US
MAY THINK THEY'RE RECYCLABLE
THEY ACTUALLY ARE NOT RECYCLED
BECAUSE THERE'S A LACK OF THE
MARKETPLACE THIS BUILDS UPON
THE BILL THAT MYSELF WITH THE
MEMBER IRWIN DID LAST YEAR AB
SEVEN NINETY THREE TO SET.
MINIMUM CYCLE CONTENT FOR
PLASTIC BEVERAGE BOTTLES SO BY
USING THAT SAME MODEL WE HOPE
TO REALLY CHANGE THE DEMAND FOR
THESE THERMOFORMED PRODUCTS
ACROSS OUR VERY STATE. WITHOUT
A WHICH IN TURN OVER TO MY
JOINT AUTHORS FROM THE. NUMBER
ONE AND THEN WE HAVE TO
WITNESSES. THANK YOU MISTER AND
TO MY JOY AUTHORS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO AB FOR A FOUR SEVEN
EIGHT IS A BIG STEP FOR
CALIFORNIA TO TAKE THE LEAD IN
CREATING THE CIRCULAR ECONOMY.
IT PROVIDES INCENTIVES TO PULL
OUT A HIGHLY RECYCLABLE
MATERIAL FROM THE WASTE STREAM.
AND THROUGH THE MINIMUM CONTENT
REQUIREMENT TO CREATE A MARKET
FOR THAT MATERIAL. FURTHER THE
BILL INCREASES THE SUPPLY OF
RECYCLED P. E. T. WHICH IS
SEEING AN INCREASE IN DEMAND
FROM SEVERAL. INDUSTRIES WHILE
THERE REMAIN A FEW OUTSTANDING
ITEMS TO ADDRESS WE ARE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH ALL OUR STAKEHOLDERS AND
WITH THAT I WILL PASS IT BACK.
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO. MR GIVEN
THE ENTHUSIASM OF THE TWO-
AUTHORS HERE TO. WORK ON THE
CIRCULAR ECONOMY AND- AND
ADDRESS THIS OF RECYCLE
PROBLEMS I WOULD MOVE THE
MATTER AS AMENDED. AND THANK
YOU. OKAY SO LET'S NOW GO TO
LEAD WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WE'VE
GOT BOB DEBITED FROM OUR PLANET
EARTH ON THE CO HOST PHONE LINE
WE ALSO HAVE SCOTT WILKERSON
FROM BONDUELLE FRESH AMERICAS-
SO LET'S TURN TO THOSE TWO
WITNESSES FIRST. OKAY THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING- THIS IS BOB W.
COME THE CO FOUNDER AND CO CEO
OF THE COMPANY ARE PLANET
EARTH. I DON'T THE BANK CHAIR
ALAN AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
PAINTING IN THIS- COMMITTEE
HEARING. ARE WE ARE PROUD TO BE
THE SPONSOR OF AB FOUR SEVEN
EIGHT. THANKS TO A COMBINATION
OF PUBLIC AND PRIVATE CAPITAL
OUR PLANET EARTH IS THE WORLD'S
FIRST MANUFACTURE OF RECYCLED
P. E. T. ALSO KNOWN AS HARP AT.
PACKAGING OTHER PRODUCTS ARE
DERIVED FROM POST CONSUMER BAIL
PET CONTAINERS BOTH BOTTLES AND
THERMAL FORMS THAT WE RECYCLE
IN A QUAKE FORM AND CONVERTING
THE NEW BEVERAGE AND FOOD
CONTAINERS ARE COMPLETELY
PERFECTLY INTEGRATED FACILITY
LOCATED IN BURNING CALIFORNIA.
WE EMPLOYED TWO HUNDRED PEOPLE
AND AS WE GROW WE CONTINUE TO
ADD ADDITIONAL. STAFF HERE IN
BERLIN. SINCE THE ENTIRE MAY.
PROCESS OCCURS IN SINK ROOF THE
GREENHOUSE GAS YOU. ASSOCIATE
WITH OUR- ARE AMONG THE IN THE-
AB FOUR SEVEN EIGHT WILL COVER
MOST FORM CONTAINERS USED FOR
FOOD AND BEVERAGES. INCLUDING
ITEMS SUCH AS PRODUCE EMBURY
CLAM SHELLS IN CONTAINERS
SANDWICH CONTAINERS YOUR CUPS
COFFEE PODS FROM TAKEOUT
CONTAINERS AND DRINKING CUPS.
IT WILL CREATE MARKET DEMAND
FOR A MATERIAL THAT FOR THE
MOST PART IS BEING LANDFILLS
TODAY AND IT IS A CLOSED LOOP
SOLUTION. THERE ARE APPROX
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
POUNDS OF POST CONSUMER
THERMOFORMING DISCARDED IN
CALIFORNIA EVERY YEAR AND
GROWING- IF SOMEONE CHANGES
CORRECT TWO HUNDRED MILLION
POUNDS OF THAT SYSTEM PDT
CONTAINERS. FOR FURTHER HAS
PIONEERED THE- TO MAKE THEM A
FORM TO THERMAL FORM IN
CALIFORNIA THEREBY CLOSING THE
LOOP ON A SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
PET THERMOFORMED CONTAINERS
THAT ARE DISCARDED. IN THE
STATE EVERY YEAR. HOWEVER TOO
MUCH OF THIS VALUABLE MATERIAL
IS STILL CENTRAL. AT THE
PRESENT TIME ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES WITH A LACK OF
COLLECTION THIS MATERIAL TO BE
AVAILABLE FOR RECYCLING. AB
FOUR SEVEN EIGHT WILL CREATE
MARKET DEMAND AND INCREASED
COLLECTION OF POST CONSUMER
DEMAND FOR CONTAINERS. WHICH
WILL DIVERT THEM FROM
LANDFILLS. AND WHAT THE MOST
RECENT AMENDMENTS TO EXCLUDE
DEMO FORMS FROM THE COMMINGLED
RATE. IT WILL ALSO CAN. ISSUES
ABOUT SIERRA BALES AND
ENCOURAGE THERMAL FORMS TO BE
SEPARATELY BELT. WE HAVE SEEN
POSITIONS TAKEN BY SOME THAT WE
BELIEVE ARE AT ODDS WITH THE
INTENT OF AB FOUR SEVEN EIGHT
FOR EXAMPLE THE PROPOSAL TO
HAVE DIFFERENT MINIMUM RECYCLED
CONTENT REQUIREMENTS BY RESIN
TYPE. BURKE SCREWED OTHERS OUT
RIGHT MAY CREATE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. FOR EXAMPLE DOING
SO MAY ENCOURAGE BRANDS AND
RETAILERS TO SWITCH TO RUGBY
TYPES WITH THE LOWEST MINIMUM
RECYCLED CONTENT REQUIREMENTS.
THEREBY DIMINISHING THE IMPACT
OF AB FOUR SEVEN EIGHT.
INCREASING THE AMOUNT OF TIME A
FORM SENT TO LANDFILL AND
PORTING THE GOALS OF THIS
LEGISLATION. WATER CONTENT
LEVELS ARE LOWER THAN THAT OF
AB SEVEN NINETY THREE THE
MAJORITY OF NEW CLAM SHELLS ARE
EXPORTED OUT OF STATE. IT'S NOT
AVAILABLE FOR COLLECTION EVEN
THOUGH WE EXPECT THE MAJORITY
OF EXPORTED BERMAN FORMS ALSO
CONTAIN POST CONSUMER TELEPHONE
CONTACT. THIS IS DUE TO THE WAY
THE CLAM SHELLS ARE PURCHASED
AND BERRIES AND VOTERS ARE
PACKED IN THE FIELD. THE BILL
WINCH THE MAN AMOUNT OF
CONSUMER BERMAN. I CLASS. TO
RECYCLE RATE OF THAT SAME THAN
TRY IN ORDER TO DRIVE MARKETS.
AB FOUR SEVEN EIGHT WILL
INCREASE THE DEMAND FOR STATE
POST CONSUMER PLASTIC RESINS.
BUDGETS PJ AND POLY. THEY'RE BY
ENCOURAGING RECYCLERS THAT DO
NOT HAVE THE FDA'S ALLEN-
DESIGNATION TO OBTAIN IT.
BECAUSE THE DEMAND WILL EXISTS
TO JUSTIFY THE INVESTMENT
REQUIRED TO COLLECT AND RECYCLE.
THE VARIOUS RESIN TYPES. WE
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR CARRYING THE BILL AND FOR
THE COMMITTEE TIENEN. BY AFTER
YEARS OF ON THIS MEASURE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME MORNING.
THANK YOU. I'M MISDIRECTED COCA
A QUITE A BIT OF THE PRO SIDE
TESTIMONY SO MISTER WILKERSON
IF YOU COULD KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS- SHORT I'D APPRECIATE
THAT. ABSOLUTELY GOOD MORNING-
THANK YOU CHAIR ALAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY I
MEAN IT'S GOT 1% AND THE CHIEF
PROCUREMENT OFFICER AT
BONDUELLE FRESH AMERICAS. YOU
KNOW IT'S IS READY PAC FOODS
AND OUR BISTRO GRANTS. PROBABLY
BASED IN IRWINDALE AND CHILENOS
AND WE'RE ONE OF THE NATIONAL
LEADERS IN FRESH VEGETABLES
SALADS AND FRESH MAIL
SOLUTIONS. HERE WE ARE PLEASED
TO JOIN WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS AND
SUPPORTING EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT. CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO
SET THE PACE FOR THE REST OF
THE NATION AND THE COUNTRY'S
LARGEST AGRICULTURAL PRODUCER
AND EXPORTER. AND THERMOFORM
PACKAGING SUCH AS CLAM SHELLS
HAS ALSO REVOLUTIONIZED.
UTILITY FOR CALIFORNIA FARMERS
TO TRANSPORT THEIR FRESH
PRODUCE TO CONSUMERS NATIONWIDE.
WELL DIRECT THE AND PACKAGING
MADE WITH POST CONSUMER
RECYCLED CONTENT ARE
INCREASINGLY A GLOBAL PRIORITY
FOR THE WORLD'S LARGEST
CONSUMER BRANDED RETAILERS. FOR
EXAMPLE OUR COMPANY'S OBJECTIVE
IS BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AB
1100% OF OUR PACKAGING DESIGN
TO BE RECYCLABLE OR REUSABLE.
PREVIOUSLY MOST OF THAT RECYCLE
MATERIALS FROM PLASTIC BOTTLES
WHICH INCREASINGLY IN HIGH
DEMAND. ESPECIALLY WITH THE
PASSAGE OF EIGHTY SEVEN NINE
THREE WHICH SETS MINIMUM
CONTENT I'M PLASTIC BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS. WE ARE FACED WITH
THE CHALLENGE WHERE COMMUNITIES
ARE NOT CURRENTLY COLLECTING
THERMOFORMED CONTAINERS
UNLOCKED TO SUPPORT ADEQUATE
SUPPLY WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY FOUR SEVEN EIGHT
BECAUSE IT WILL HELP ENCOURAGE
THE COLLECTION OF THIS
RECYCLABLE MATERIAL AND ENABLE
US. TO MEET OUR SUSTAINABILITY
GOALS THROUGH THE RECYCLED
CONTENT MANDATE THE BILL ALSO
IS NEEDED TO CREATE A LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD WE HAVE MADE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS AND
RECYCLABLE PRODUCT BUT ALSO HAS
RECYCLED CONTENT AND THIS BILL
WILL PROPEL THE ENTIRE SUPPLY
CHAIN TOWARD MORE
ENVIRONMENTALLY RESPONSIBLE
PACKAGING. IN SOME WE WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM FOR
CARRYING THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND AB
FOUR SEVEN EIGHT AND I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU OKAY LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINES. OUTSIDE TO SEE IF
ANYONE WANTS TO VOICE THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. MODERATOR
THANK YOU THE STATE SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL YOU MAY PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. ONCE AGAIN
THAT- TO THE ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. WE DO HAVE SEVERAL LINES
IN Q. MOBILE FIRST ONLINE.
TWENTY SEVEN. YES THAT AND
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE POWER TREAT ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE REQUIREMENT
BANKERS AND THE COALITION WE
PUT TOGETHER WITH THE CHECK A I
PLANET EARTH FONDLING READY PAC
AND OTHERS AND CALLED THE PORT.
NEXT DEADLINE FORTY FIVE. GOOD
MORNING JERRY MEMBERS
PERSONALLY IT OFF ON BEHALF OF
YOUR CLIENT CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO AND
GOOD FOR AND ON BEHALF OF
NATIONAL ACTION COUNCIL WE WANT
THANK YOUNG TECH BROADER WORK
ON THE CONVERSATION AND-
ADDRESSING A KEY CONCERN. THANK
YOU. LINE FIFTY FIVE ZERO. GOOD
MORNING SURE NUMBERS NIKITA
KARATE WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY
THREE. GOOD MORNING JONATHAN
CLAIM TO HAVE THE COUNTY SAN
DIEGO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINE FIFTY FOUR. GOOD MORNING
KAREN MEMBERS GENEVIEVE ABDON
ON BEHALF OF THE CREAM HE'S
LOBBYING COALITION IN SUPPORT.
NINE FORTY SEVEN. GOOD MORNING
TURN MEMBERS CATHERINE DODD
WITH THE ALLIANCE OF NURSES FOR
A HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT AND WE'RE
IN SUPPORT. MY NAME FORTY
EIGHT. C. GET THE DOG OUTSIDE
BILL CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE
AND ALSO CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND WHAT.
THANK YOU KNOW THE LINES IN Q.
ONE SUPPORT AT THIS TIME OKAY
THANK YOU MATTER LET'S NOW TURN
TO OPPOSITION WE'VE GOT DEL DEL
HAD FROM THE WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO TIM CHESTER.
FROM THE AMERICAN CHEMISTRY
COUNCIL WE CAN HEAR FROM THEM.
THANK YOU SENATE ALLEN CAN YOU
HEAR ME OK. YES I CAN HEAR YOU
FINE YEP. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS I THINK THE
AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL I
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY TODAY WE CURRENTLY
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL AND WE'RE
CERTAINLY SUPPORTIVE OF
ESTABLISHING A MINIMUM RECYCLED
CONTENT REQUIREMENTS FOR THESE
CONTAINERS THAT YOU BELIEVE
SOME AMENDMENTS ARE NECESSARY
AROUND. A TECHNICAL FEASIBILITY
THE NEED TO ACCOUNT FOR
AVAILABLE SUPPLY OF RECYCLED
RESIN AND PROVIDE MANUFACTURED
SOME ADDITIONAL COMPLIANCE
FLEXIBILITY. WE ALSO HAVE A
QUESTION REGARDING THE SCOPE OF
IMPACT PACKAGING THERE HAS BEEN
A LOT OF DISCUSSION AROUND OF
FOOD CONTAINERS BUT THE CURRENT
DEFINITION IN THE BILL OF
THERMOFORM PLASTIC CONTAINERS
PRETTY BROADENED WHAT IMPACT
RIDE IF INDUSTRY WILL BE ON
FOOD SO SOME CLARIFICATION- WE
BELIEVE IS NECESSARY THERE.
WELL WE GOT A FEW TO BUILD
CONCERN THE BILL PROPOSE A VERY
AMBITIOUS. I RECYCLE LEVEL THAN
RECYCLING RATE. GIVEN CURRENT
MARKET CONDITIONS- RECLAMATION.
AND YOU AT FTA REQUIREMENTS FOR
USING RECYCLED RESIDENTS WHO
PACKAGING. THE AVAILABLE SUPPLY
YOUR RESIDENT. UNLIKELY
SUFFICIENT TO KEEP THE MANDATE
LEVEL. SO DID OF THE CONCERNS
WE WILL DO OUR CONSIDERING OF
THE AMENDMENT- ONE OF WITH
ALLOW FOR THE USE OF MATERIAL
OR NON FORM SOURCES THE NEW
COMPLIANCE OBLIGATIONS. I WOULD
TO SEE A MARKET OF THE PPR
LEVEL TO BE MORE TECHNICALLY
FEASIBLE I 10% BY TWENTY TWENTY
BY 20% BY TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
AND 30% BY TWENTY THIRTY. AND
ALSO CONSIDER RECYCLE- BEING
AUTHORIZED TO INCREASE THE
PERCENTAGES AFTER TWENTY THIRTY
BASED ON AN ASSESSMENT OF
COMPLIANCE DATE RECLAMATION
CAPACITY AND MARKET CONDITIONS.
WE DO APPRECIATE LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL THAT PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR A REDUCTION IN
THE ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTY.
SHOULD ANY FACTOR NOT BEING
COMPLIANT. WE ALSO BELIEVE
THERE SHOULD BE A PROCESS BY
WHICH MANY FACTORS THAT THE
KITCHEN POWER CYCLE ONE
INVESTMENT IN BOTH THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTY LEVEL
AND WE ARE. PERCENTAGES THAT
PROCESS COULD. INCLUDE SOME
CLEAR GUIDELINES AND- AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR LOCAL PROVIDERS
YOU ARE. IN ADDITION TO THE YOU
THANK YOU SUBMIT. OUR RECYCLE
BIN AT THAT. LOCATION FILE GETS
ON THE ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTY
FOR- WE DO APPRECIATE THAT FOR
I UNDERSTAND IT IT'S- PURPOSE
BUT YOU BELIEVE CAL RECYCLE THE
FIRST UNDERTAKEN. MORE CLEARLY
UNDER THE- THAT THAT MAYBE NAY
TO IMPROVE COLLECTION AND
PROCESSING IN. FOR THE-
APPRECIATE THE TIME TODAY AND
THE FORTY WORKING BUT- ASSEMBLY
WORKING- ANOTHER. TO CRAPPIE
WERE AND PEACEABLE A BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU TIM APPRECIATE
THAT I'M THANK YOU FROM THE-
FROM THE WESTERN GROWTH
ASSOCIATION. IT MORE MEMBERS.
AS YOU KNOW OUR LOW AND
REGIONAL FAMILY FOR GROW FRESH.
IN ARIZONA CALIFORNIA COLORADO
AND NEW MEXICO. OUR MEMBERS AND
THEIR WORKERS PROVIDE OVER HALF
THE NATION'S FRESH FRUITS
VEGETABLES AND TREE NUTS
INCLUDING NEARLY HALF OF
AMERICANS FRESH ORGANIC PRODUCE.
PACKAGING PLAYS A CRITICAL ROLE
IN PRESERVING THE INTEGRITY OF
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES PROVIDE
CONSUMERS WITH SAFE AND HEALTHY
FOOD. AND REDUCES GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS BY EXTENDING ITS
SHELF LIFE TO AVOID FOOD WASTE.
MANY OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT OF ALTERNATIVE FOOD
PACKAGING AND HAVE STUDIED HOW
TO TRANSITION FROM USING THE
RPG BOTTLES TO RECYCLE PT
CLAMSHELL FOR THEIR SOURCE OF
RECYCLED CONTENT. WESTERN
GROWERS MEMBERS ARE VERY
SUPPORTED OF RECYCLING OUR
PLASTIC CONTAINERS. HOWEVER WE
SEE SOME ISSUES IN THIS BILL
THAT WE'D LIKE FOR YOU TO
CONSIDER. FIRST THE PT FOR
MCCORMACK CONTAINERS. IT SHOULD
BE CONSIDERED RECYCLABLE AND
SHOULD BE MENTIONED IN THE BILL
AND FURTHER CONSUMERS NEED TO
HAVE AND KNOW THAT THE CLAM
SHELL CAN GO INTO THE RECYCLE
BINS TO BE COLLECTED CURBSIDE.
AND SECOND THE BILL IS NOT
REALLY CLEAR ON WHO ACTUALLY IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR VARIOUS
COMPLIANCE OBLIGATIONS. AND MAY
PUSH FARMERS IN THE POSITION OF
FACING ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS
FIRST PORTAIL YEAR OF THE
RECYCLING MARKET PLACE TO
FUNCTION PROPERLY. ENTER THE
LANGUAGE PROVIDES AN EXTREMELY
NARROW EXEMPTION IF THE CROP IS
PACKAGED IN THE FIELD AFTER
HARVESTING BUT DID NOT PROVIDE
ANY RELIEF FROM THE GROWER WHO
HARVEST THEIR FRESH PRODUCE IN
THE FIELD. AND TAKE THE TO THE
PACKING HOUSE TO BE COOLED AND
PACKAGED. IS ROUGHLY NO OFF
RAMP. IF THERE IS INSUFFICIENT
PRODUCTION OR AVAILABILITY OF
RECYCLED P. E. T. RAW MATERIALS
TO MEET THE RECYCLE CONTENT
REQUIREMENTS. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS OUR
CONCERNS. OKAY THANK YOU- I'M
SURE WILL HAVE A CHANCE DURING
DISCUSSION AND TO TALK ABOUT
ALL THESE ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED WELL LET'S TURN TO THE
PHONE LINES TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE YOU'D LIKE TO
REGISTER THEIR OPPOSITION OR
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL. AB
FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU TO
REGISTER OPPOSITION TO AB FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AGAIN THAT
PROMPT IS ONE AND THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE. TO HAVE A TWO
LINES IN Q. HERE WE JUST A
MOMENT PLEASE.
WE'LL GO FIRST
TO THE LINE OF TWENTY NINE TO
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU SIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
BOARD AYE YOU ARE ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN INSTITUTE FOR
PACKAGING IN THE ENVIRONMENT
AND THE FLEXIBLE PACKAGING
ASSOCIATION ALSO AND- POSE THE
MOST IMMINENT POSITION. ON THE
OTHER LINE. FIFTY TWO. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CODY
BOILED ME HALF THE CALIFORNIA
FRESH FRUIT ASSOCIATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA STRAWBERRY
COMMISSION WITH OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION THANK YOU.
THANK MISTER JOURNAL FOR THE
LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU OKAY LET'S BRING THE
ITEM BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
DISCUSSION. I'M MAYBE WHAT WE
DO WE CAN GIVE THE AUTHORS AND
AN OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND SOME
OF THE CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION ON THE- LEGALLY
TESTED WEEKLY TESTIMONY YEP.
THAT WE DEFINITELY ARE LOOKING
AT TAKING AMENDMENTS TO THE
NEXT COMMITTEE TO FURTHER
DEFINE SPECIFICALLY WHICH TERM
OF FORMS PART TALKING ABOUT WE
APPRECIATE THE FEEDBACK. AND WE
ALSO WILL BE CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH OPPOSITION REALLY AROUND.
RECYCLING LANGUAGES WHILE
RECYCLING EDUCATION NO THAT'S
ONE OF THEIR- ISSUES TO WE DO
APPRECIATE THAT AT THE BACK
FROM THAT WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
DISCUSSIONS. IT IS. YES BECAUSE
THIS. SO IT'S BEEN DOUBLE OR
FOR A GREAT. RIGHT I'M- OKAY
SURE I GUESS I GUESS IF I'M
READING INTO WHAT THE-
OPPOSITION SAYING WE'RE MAKING
A DISTINCTION BETWEEN POST
CONSUMER RECYCLED. NON THERMAL
FIVE PLASTIC AND POST CONSUMER
PLASTIC IS PHILIP WE'RE TRYING
TO BUILD THESE INDUSTRIES WOULD
RECYCLE MATERIALS WERE TO WERE
SEGREGATING THAT THE- THERMAL
FORM. FORM OF PLASTIC
CONTAINERS VERSUS THE OTHER
TYPES OF PLASTICS FROM
OVERNIGHT OVER SIMPLIFYING DATA
THAT YOU'VE BEEN VISION WHAT
THERE WILL BE A WHOLE CLOSED
LOOP WHICH IS THE THERMAL FORM
PLASTICS. N. I THINK THE OBJECT
THE OBJECTION IS THAT IF THE
MARKET DOESN'T. BUILD UP IN THE
NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS CAN WE
SUBSTITUTE WITH RECYCLED
MATERIAL BUT NOT ON THE-
THERMAL FORM. IS AT AN
OVERSIMPLIFICATION OF WHAT.
WHERE WE'RE AT. AN ACCOMPLICE
HATED PROCESS BUT OBVIOUSLY WE
ARE TRYING TO DRIVE DEMAND BY
HAVING AND MINIMUM RECYCLED
CONTENT REQUIREMENT AND IT AND
IT'S VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT WE
DID WITH THE- WITH THE BILL FOR
SEVENTY EIGHT BY I MEAN AND THE
CLASSICS BILL FROM LAST YEAR
BUT THE NINETY THREE. NINETY
THREE BY THE FAR YOU'RE REALLY
DRIVING YOUR DRIVING DEMAND
PREFERRED IF I RECALL THE- THE
BOTTLE BUILD BUG FAXES PLASTIC
WE REQUIRED A MINIMUM CONTENT
BUT WE DIDN'T SAY IT COULD NOT
BE. THERMAL FORM PLASTIC- SORT
OF- WHAT TO YOU PICK WITH US
ANY SEE ANY ANY APPROPRIATE
PLASTIC THAT WAS RECYCLED SO
IT'S THEM I MEAN I LOOK FORWARD
I'M GOING TO SUPPORTING THE
MEASURE BUT IT'S AS THE
MARKET'S MATURE AND YOU HAVE
THIS SEGREGATION- OF THE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PLASTIC
OBVIOUSLY THE ONE HAVE
DIFFERENT TARGETS FOR DIFFERENT
DIFFERENT TYPES OF YOU SO- LOOK
FOR TO CONTENTION TO IT AND FOR
THAT FOR THE BOTTLES YOU DO
NEED TO USE THAT THAT SPECIFIC
TYPE OF PLASTIC AND THAT'S HOW
YOU CREATE THE CIRCULAR ECONOMY
FOR THE THERMA FORMS. YOU CAN
ALSO USE THE BOOK THEY THEY
HAVE BEEN USING THE BOTTLES BUT
THAT WOULD BE THAT WOULD MAKE
THEM MARKET FOR BOTTLES MORE
DIFFICULT THAT'S WHY YOU'RE
REALLY TRYING TO GET THE
CIRCULAR ECONOMY WITH- THE JUST
THE THERMAL FORMS BUT ALSO
SINCE WE'RE DOING A GOOD JOB OF
RECYCLING POTOM TO LEAVE THAT
THAT'S NOT TODAY'S. DISCUSSIONS
WILL HAVE THAT LATER. ALL
RIGHT. YES SENATE SKINNER. I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHORS FOR
BRING THE BILL- YOU KNOW
THERE'S A- I THINK MOST
CALIFORNIANS ARE SOPHISTICATED
ENOUGH TO KNOW. THAT JUST
PUTTING SOMETHING IN A
RECYCLING BIN IS NOT RECYCLING.
AND THAT UNLESS THE PRODUCT. IS
RE MANUFACTURED. MEANING UNLESS
THE PRODUCT IS TAKEN AND THEN
HOWEVER TRANSFORM TO BE RE
MANUFACTURED INTO ANOTHER
PRODUCT THERE IS NO RECYCLING.
AND SO. THIS WILL HELP US
ACHIEVE THEIR GOALS AND
PLASTICS OF COURSE HAVE BEEN
ONE OF THE MOST OF THEIR
UBIQUITOUS NOW THEY'RE ONE OF
THE MOST DIFFICULT BECAUSE OF
THE- WE'VE NOT HAD ADEQUATE
RULES. ON WHAT THE CONTENT OF
THE PLASTIC IS THE CAN MADE UP
OF SO MANY DIFFERENT POLYMERS
THAT IT'S OFTEN TIMES IN MOST
IMPOSSIBLE TO THEN TAKE THAT
MATERIAL AND- YOU SAID IN
ANOTHER MATERIAL- AND OF COURSE
WE ALL KNOW. THAT A LITTLE
SYMBOL ON THE PARTICULAR
PACKAGE DOES NOT ALSO INDICATE
THAT IT'S REALLY YOU KNOW MAYBE
THEORETICALLY IT MIGHT BE
RECYCLABLE BUT IT HAVE ANYTHING
TO DO WITH THE ACTUAL. RE USE
OF THAT MATERIAL SO I THINK
THIS WILL HELP US GET THERE I.
ACTUALLY I THINK THAT- IF WE
TAKE THE THREE OURS REDUCE
REUSE RECYCLE YOU NOTICE THAT
RECYCLE IS THE THIRD OF THE
THREE R'S THAT REDUCTION IS THE
FIRST AND FOREMOST GOAL. BUT IN
THE MEANTIME. THIS IS A GOOD
STEP THERE. OKAY ARE THE ITEMS
REMOVED BY CENTER WITH CASKEY-
IF THE OTHERS LIKE TO CLOSE- WE
THINK THIS IS A GREAT- SECOND
STEP WITH ARGUMENT OF
COMPLEMENT THE BEVERAGE BOTTLE
BILL THAT WE DID. WE THINK THAT
THIS IS THE BILL AT THE NEXT
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE A
CIRCULAR ECONOMY WITH FORMER
FORMS WHICH ARE LIKE CENTER
SKINNER SAID- ACTUALLY YOU PICK
WHAT IS AT THIS POINT. ADJUSTER
I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER IPHONE.
OKAY THANK YOU I'M COMPLETELY.
I AM NUMBER ONE EIGHTY FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT BY- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STING AND IRWIN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY HI.
ALLEN HI. BATES DOLLY GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I SKINNER AYE SKINNER
AYE STERN WHITE HOUSE SKI. OKAY
SO WILL HOLD THE ROLE OF IN
THANK YOU SO MUCH MEMBERS AND
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A ROLL
TOGETHER FOLKS TO ADD ON. R. S.
C. ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
HERE SHE CAN PRESENT ITEM
NUMBER THREE IN YOUR AGENDAS
MEMBERS THIS IS- AB ELEVEN
FORTY SEVEN. YOU MAY PERCEIVE
AND READY. THERE ARE A MEMBERS
I WANT TO THANK YOU FIRST OF
ALL MISTER CHAIR FOR YOU AND
YOUR COMMITTEES HELP WITH THIS
BILL WE RAN OUT OF TIME TO GET
MANY OF THE- AMENDMENTS- INTO
PRINT- BUT WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH YOUR OFFICE AND ALSO THE
OFFICE OF SENATOR LINCOLN'S
ALWAYS FROM TRANSPORTATION WITH
THIS BILL IS GOING NEXT TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS THAT WERE
RAISED IN THE ANALYSIS AND WILL
BE TAKING AMENDMENTS AND SENATE
TRANSPORTATION. AB FORTY SEVEN-
IS TRYING TO TAKE A MULTI
FACETED APPROACH TO HELPING THE
STATE IN OUR NGOS IN OUR LOCAL
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS REDUCE
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED AS YOU
ALL KNOW DARRELL STEINBERG- IN
HIS SEMINAL TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
LEGISLATION S. B. THREE SEVENTY
FIVE ABOUT SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES. THE OF THE ASKED
COMMUNITIES TO PLAN FOR
REDUCING VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
IN MANY DIFFERENT WAYS BUT
UNFORTUNATELY OVER THE YEARS.
DESPITE THE EXTREMELY WELL
INTENTIONED GOALS OF THAT BILL
WE'VE SEEN BY A CAR WHILE
TROUBLED INCREASING CALIFORNIA
WE'VE GONE THE WRONG DIRECTION.
THIS BILL MAKES VARIOUS CHANGES
IN OUR PROCESSES AND OUR GOAL
SETTING. AND ALSO. TO TRY TO
HELP WITH THAT. AND ALSO-
PROPOSES A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF FUNDING. TO HELP OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES NOT JUST PLAN BUT
ALSO TO CONSTRUCT. PROJECTS
THAT WILL REDUCE VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED. IT'S NOT A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL APPROACH IT ALLOWS FOR
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES TO TAKE
VERY DIFFERENT STRATEGIES- TO
CHANGE LAND USE TO IMPACT
PEOPLE'S- NEST NECESSITY TO
DRIVE. AND IT ALSO PROVIDES A
LOT OF INCENTIVES WITH THE- OF
USE OF A COMPETITIVE GRANT-
PROGRAM. TO HELP COMMUNITIES
WITH PLANNING AND WITH
CONSTRUCTION- THAT WITH THAT WE
HAVE TODAY IT WILL BE AIRED
FROM THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA. AND
JULIA RANDOLPH FROM THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. AND I THINK
THEY'RE AVAILABLE BY FRANKIE
BROWN. YEP THANK YOU THIS IS
WILL BEAR AT THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU CAROLYN
MEMBERS AND ENSURE ON YOUR
ONGOING INTEREST IN THIS
IMPORTANT TOPIC AS WELL.
ESTACION SECTOR IS THE LEADING
SOURCE OF CALIFORNIANS HARMFUL
ERIN CLIMATE POLLUTION WITHOUT
A COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
HEALTHIER MORE SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION THAT SERVES ALL
RESIDENTS. CALIFORNIA WILL
SIMPLY NOT MEET OUR HELP
PROTECT OF CLEAN AIR AND
CLIMATE STANDARDS. LAND USE AND
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING IS
CENTRAL TO THE DISCUSSION
CALIFORNIA IS NOT ON TRACK TO
ACHIEVING THE CLIMATE HEALTH
EQUITY AND SUSTAINABILITY GOALS
ENVISIONED BY SENATE BILL THREE
SEVENTY FIVE. AB ELEVEN FORTY
SEVEN IS AN IMPORTANT
OPPORTUNITY TO SECURE THE
BENEFITS OF HEALTH YOUR
COMMUNITIES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. ESPECIALLY FOR
MOST DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
WHERE AIR POLLUTION BURDENS ARE
OFTEN MORE EXTREME. THAN ACROSS
THE STATE. AB ELEVEN FORTY
SEVEN WITH SUPPORT GETTING
CALIFORNIA ON TRACK BY BRINGING
LOCAL REGIONAL AND STATE
AGENCIES TOGETHER TO IDENTIFY
BARRIERS TO ACHIEVING REGIONAL
CLIMATE GOALS WITHIN THEIR OWN
LOCAL CONTACTS- INCLUDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MPO TO
CONSULT WITH LOCAL AGENCIES ON
CHALLENGES PREVENTING THE
ACHIEVEMENT ORIGINAL TARGETS.
AND ESTABLISHES THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR MPO TO DEVELOP A TARGET
ACTION PLAN THAT WOULD HELP TO
IDENTIFY ANY KEY BARRIERS TO
IMPLEMENTATION OR ACHIEVEMENT
OF THEIR REGIONAL GREENHOUSE
GAS TARGETS. OUTRAGE TO AND
REPORTS REALLY IMPORTANTLY OF
INPUT FROM DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. AND THEN
CORRECTIVE ACTIONS FOR AN MPO
TO MEET ITS TWENTY THIRTY FIVE
REGIONAL TARGET. UPON THE
COMPLETION OF THAT MPO- TARGET
ACTION PLAN IF YOU LIVE IN
FORTY SEVEN WOULD MAKE BLOCK
GRANT FUNDING AVAILABLE TO
SUPPORT ACTIONSNEEDED TO
REDUCE VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
TO ADVANCE EQUITY AND TO MEET
REGIONAL GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION REDUCTION TARGETS THAT
BUILD HEALTHIER COMMUNITIES. IF
YOU'RE SEEKING TO ACCELERATE
ACTIONS TO ACHIEVE THEIR
HEALTHCARE COMMUNITIES BUT BY
CURRENT FUNDING CAN REALLY
SERVE AS A MAJOR PUSH IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AND HELP TO
CORRECT THE COURSE. THAT WE'VE
HAD SO FAR NOT BEEN ABLE TO
MAINTAIN IN ACHIEVING SB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE VISION. THAT WE
ARE HERE AYE VOTE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. DID YOU MISTER
BARRETT LET'S SAY MEXICO TO
JULIE RANDALL FROM THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR. GOOD
MORNING JERRY MEMBERS THIS IS
JULIE ARAMBULA I AM A PART OF
THE ENTIRE REGION THAT YET FOR
THE COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR. IN
POLYESTER BURIED COMMON PLEAS
COURT AB ELAM FORTY SEVEN AS IT
WOULD SIGNIFICANTLY- CREATED
THE STATE EFFORT TO PROVIDE
TRANSPORTATION CHOICES THAT
REDUCE HARMFUL AIR AND CLIMATE
POLLUTION. LOGICAL MILES
TRAVELED CALIFORNIA HAS LED THE
NATION IN APPLYING ADVANCED
TECHNOLOGY VEHICLE ENGINE AND
PROMPTING INNOVATION IN
TRANSPORTATION YOUR- BUT WE
HAVE STRUGGLING TO ALIGN LAND
USE WITH THE NEED TO REDUCE THE
ENERGY AND THE CORRESPONDING
EMISSION THAT CAUSE. AIR
POLLUTION AND CLIMATE CHANGE
THE PASSING OF SB THREE SEVENTY
FIVE BY DIVERTING TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT REACH HELP- PAIRED AND
CHEF SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE IT'S
NOT YIELDING IT ENDED CLIMATE
HEALTH EQUITY IN CONSERVATION
RESULT. WITH THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR BEING THE LEADING SOURCE
OF BEARING CLIMATE POLLUTION
REDUCTION B. AND G. P. AB
ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN TAKE A MULTI
FACETED APPROACH THAT
CALIFORNIA ON THE COURSE TO BE
ITS GHG EMISSION REDUCTION
TARGETS EXPECTED UNDER AT.
THREE SEVENTY FIVE BY MAKING
CHANGES THAT THE STATE LOCAL
AND REGIONAL LEVEL RIGHT TOOL
ACCOUNTABILITY AND INCENTIVES.
FOR NPL CAN MEET THEIR TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE AB ELEVEN FORTY
SEVEN REGIONAL GHG EMISSION
TARGET. THE BELLOWING REQUIRE
EACH AND P. L. DEGREE AT TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE TARGET ACTION PLAN
DEVELOPING NEW BLACK GRANT
PROGRAMS TO HELP. ACHIEVE THEIR
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE GOALS AND
REQUIRE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
MAKE GOOD FAITH EFFORTS TO TAKE
ACTION BACK THERE AND BE-
GLOBAL STRATEGY. FONG I WOULD
INCLUDED IT IN CIGNA ATTENTION
TO ISSUE WITH THAT WITHIN THE
MOBILE STRIVE AND THE OF
MEETING POLITICAL AIR CLIMATE
STANDARD. AFTER TRANSPORTATION
LAST BY A BY ROLE IN. AFTER TO
REDUCE AIR POLLUTION GIGI THE
EMPLOYEE. WALKING AND BICYCLING
ALSO HAD MANY POSITIVE. THANK
YOU THE PUBLIC HEALTH LOCAL CON
AND THE DATA AND AT. ABOUT AB
ONE FOR SEVEN ONE IS THAT IN
THE DEVELOPED OF TRANSFORM
AFTER. PART OTHER CITY THE
COUNTRIES BEEN BREAK SUCH AS-
BICYCLE HIGHWAYS AND FIFTEEN
COMMUTE. THANKS THE CAR WE WERE
A VEHICLE FORTY. AT THE WEIGHT
IMPROVE THE SUSTAINABILITY AND
LITTLE. CAL COMMUNITY WE URGE
COMMITTEE TO APPROVE THAT BELL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY
LET'S. I DON'T LET'S NOT GO TO
THE LINES IF ANYONE TO WAY IN
AND SAID. OF AB FORTY SEVEN. ON
THE PHONE. THANK YOU TO STATE
SUPPORT FOR A BI ELEVEN FORTY
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD AGAIN THAT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
PLEASE. ALTHOUGH FIRSTLINE
FIFTY FIVE OH YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU TURN NUMBERS NIKITA
KARATE WITH ENERGY FEE IN
SUPPORT. WE HAVE LINE. FORTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS
CAPTURED ON THE LINE TO NURSES
FOR A HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT IN
SUPPORT. THERE ARE NO OTHER
LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
OKAY WE DON'T HAVE ANY
REGISTERED OPPOSITION WITNESSES
AND I DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S ANY
REGISTERED OPPOSITION IN
GENERAL FOR THE BILL- BUT IF IS
ANYONE THE PHONE LINE WHO WANTS
TO EXPRESS CONCERNS ARE
OPPOSITION THE BILL. MODERATOR
THANK YOU TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AGAIN USING
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD YOU PRESS
OF ONE OF THE MISSOURI AT THIS
TIME. OVER LINE FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KIANA VALENTINE ON
BEHALF OF TRANSPORTATION
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING THE
TRANSPORTATION INDUSTRY AND
WORK FORCE THAT BUILDS REPAIRS
AND MAINTAINS CALIFORNIA'S
STATEWIDE. MULTIMODAL
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM WITH AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
I'D LIKE TO START MY TESTIMONY
BY- HIGHLIGHTING THE FACT THAT
AS I SPEAK I AM HOPING TO
FINALIZE SOME AMENDMENTS- AND
SEND THEM TO- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN STAFF FOR HER.
CONSIDERATION THAT WE ARE
HOPEFUL WILL REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION- BUT IN SHORT- OUR
CONCERNS ARE AROUND AT THE JUNE
TENTH LANGUAGE- RELATED TO HAVE
REDUCING VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED- TRANSPORTATION
CALIFORNIA IN THE INDUSTRY ARE.
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE STATE'S
CULTURE RELATED TO CLIMATE
CHANGE AND THE CURRENT-
FRAMEWORK CREATED BY SB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE WHICH DIRECTORS
MPO TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS MANY OF THE GHG
REDUCING STRATEGIES THAT NPOS
EMPLOYEE ALSO HAVE THE BENEFIT
OF CONTRIBUTING TO A REDUCTION
OF VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED. AT
BUT AT THE SAME TIME- THE M. T.
REDUCING POLICIES WE BELIEVE
OUR TOOL AND ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT AT B. M. T. GOLD BEING
ELEVATED AS THE GOAL ITSELF AND
NOT THE TOOL BY WHICH TO MEET
OUR GHG AND CLIMATE GOALS. IT'S
UNCLEAR TO US HOW THE M. T.
REDUCTION STRATEGIES INTERACT
WITH OTHER IMPORTANT STATE
GOALS- NOT THE LEAST OF WHICH-
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE IS IMPACTS
ON- LIVING WAGE. JOBS AND
ECONOMIC GROWTH. SO THOSE ARE
JUST A FEW THINGS THAT OUR OUR
CONCERNS- WITH THE BILL BUT
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS TIME AND HER
STAFF TIME WORKING WITH US AND
HOPE TO FIND SOME RESOLUTION
BEFORE ITS NEXT POLICY
COMMITTEE HEARING NEXT. WEEK
THE WEEK AFTER. THANKS SO MUCH
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN THE
FOR MY MOTHER. NO OTHER LINES
IN Q. OKAY ALL RIGHT. LET'S
BRING THEM BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS DISCUSSION
CENTERED DOLLARS. HAPPY TO MOVE
THE BILL AS WELL- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN THANK YOU AND I
KNOW YOU'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
BOTH OF OUR COMMITTEES AND I
KNOW YOU'LL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH- OPPOSITION BUT- THIS IS A
REALLY GREAT STARTED THAT
ESPECIALLY AS IT PERTAINS
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION- AND
ALLOWING THE NPOS TO REALLY
PROVIDE DATA AND GIVE THEM
TOOLS TO HELP A TOWARDS ITS
GOALS SO- THANK YOU NIGHT.
ARJUN I BUILT. THANK YOU. I
WILL THEM TO MOVE ANSWER ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR THOUGHTS
PROJECT THE- THE AUTHOR WORKING
WITH OUR COMMITTEE ON ON THIS
IMPORTANT MATTER AND- WE'LL
WE'LL TURN IT BACK TO YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO OFFER CLOSE
I WOULD JUST SAY IN TERMS OF
THE CONCERNS- FROM- FROM THE
TIME OF THE STAKEHOLDERS AND
TRANSPORTATION GROUP. I AGREE
WITH THEM REALLY THE WE SHOULD
BE FOCUSING ON THE GOAL OF
REDUCING CLIMATE EMISSIONS. AND
SOME OF WE USE THAT TERM AND
INTERCHANGEABLY WITH B. M. T.
BUT NOT ALL THE M. T. IS THE
SAME. RIGHT AND I DO BELIEVE
THAT THE BILL RECOGNIZES THAT
IT'S REALLY ABOUT THAT GOAL
SETTING. AND WITH THAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE HELP THAT YOU'VE
ALL YOU'VE ALL YOU'VE BOTH
GIVEN ME AND THE SUPPORT OF THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GREAT DOES A MOVE A SECOND.
CONSULT PLEASE COLOR. ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB ELEVEN FORTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED BUT FIRST TO BE RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION. ALLEN HI ON AYE
BATES. DOLLY DOLLY NO GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I SKINNER. SKINNER AYE
STERN WHITE HOUSE CASE BY THE
COUNCIL NINE. R. SAYS ABOUT TO
GET OUT BUT- WE WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR THIS TO ADELINE I
SEE A SUMMER CAREER HERE SHE
CAN APPROACH THE DIETS I JUST
WANNA BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
TELEVISED ON IT MAY NOT BE
QUITE EASILY ACCESSIBLE I'VE
BEEN ASKED TO REPEAT THE
PARTICIPANT NUMBER FOR FOLKS
WHO LIKE TO PREVENT PUBLIC
COMMENT. THAT NUMBER IS.
877-692-8953 THAT'S EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE THREE AN ACCESS CODE IS.
SEVEN ZERO FIVE SIX NINE OH
NINE. SEVEN ZERO FIVE SIX NINE
OH NINE SO ONCE AGAIN JUST
REMEMBER EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE THREE
ACCESS CODE SEVEN ZERO FIVE.
SIX NINE ZERO NINE AND SO WE
HAVE A CAREER HE MAY BRIDGE THE
DICE WHEN READY AT PRESENT.
YOUR BILL WHICH IS AB. TWELVE
SEVENTY SIX. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MMBERS I'M SO PROUD
TO PRESENT A SYMBOL AT TWELVE
SEVENTY SIX A MEASURE THAT WILL
BUILD ON CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING
EFFORTS TO COMBAT SINGLE USE
PLASTIC AN ITEM WASTE. WHICH
HAS BEEN EXACERBATED BY THE
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND
REDUCES. UNNECESSARY COSTS FOR
BUSINESSES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS EVERY YEAR IN THE
UNITED STATES AN ESTIMATED FIVE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO BILLION
DISPOSABLE FOOD WHERE ITEMS ARE
USED. RESULTING IN A MASSIVE
FOUR POINT NINE MILLION TONS OF
WASTE. UNUSED FOOD ACCESSORIES
INCLUDING UTENSILS STRAWS
NAPKINS AND CONDIMENT PACKAGES.
CLOG OUR LANDFILLS COMPLICATE
RECYCLING AND POLLUTES STREETS
AND WATERWAYS AND OUR
COMMUNITIES AS WE HAVE IT A
WITNESS. THE PANDEMIC HAS
INCREASED THE RELIANCE ON TAKE
OUT AND FOOD DELIVERY WHICH
RESTAURANTS HAVE RELIED UPON.
TO STAY AFLOAT AS SUCH THE USE
OF SINGLE FOOD ACCESSORIES HAS
CONTRIBUTED TO AN APPROXIMATELY
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY TO THREE
HUNDRED PERCENT. INCREASE THE
SINGLE USE PLASTICS AND A 30%
INCREASE IN WASTE. TODAY MANY
FOOD FACILITIES AND FOOD
DELIVERY SERVICE PROVIDE SINGLE
USE FOOD AND BEVERAGE
ACCESSORIES ACCESSORIES
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER OR NOT
THEY ARE NEEDED. MOST CONSUMERS
DO NOT WANT THEM OR HAVE
ALREADY HAVE REUSABLE ITEMS AT
HOME OR IN THEIR WORKPLACE. IN
THE END THESE ACCESSORIES ARE
USUALLY DISCARDED WITHOUT EVEN
BEING USED. IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE AB TWELVE SEVENTY
SIX EXPANDS. THE PLASTIC STRAW
BY REQUEST LAW TO INCLUDE OTHER
SINGLE USE WITH ACCESSORIES.
MORE FOOD FACILITIES AND THIRD
PARTY DELIVERY PLATFORMS
INCLUDING FOOD THAT IS TAKEN
AWAY DELIVERED OR SERVED ON
SITE. THIS IS A WASTE REDUCTION
MEASURE THAT REDUCES WASTE
UPSTREAM BEFORE. IT'S EVEN
CREATED EXPERTS AGREE THAT THE
SOURCE REDUCTION OF UNNECESSARY
SINGLE USE ITEMS IS BY FAR. THE
MOST EFFICIENT AND COST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO PROTECT
RESOURCES COMMUNITIES AND HELP
CALIFORNIA REACH IT'S A RACE AS
WASTE REDUCTION AND CLIMATE
GOALS. IT SAVES BUSINESSES
MONEY AND RELIEVES RECYCLERS
COMPOSTERS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FROM THE
COMPLICATIONS AND COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH IT. RESTAURANTS
IN THE US SPEND ROUGHLY
NINETEEN BILLION DOLLARS
PURCHASING DISPOSABLE FOOD
WHERE ITEMS. IN CALIFORNIA
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SPEND OVER
FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT
MILLION. ANNUALLY AND ONGOING
EFFORTS TO CLEAN UP AND PREVENT
LITTERING THE STREETS STORM
DRAINS PARKS AND WATERWAYS.
MANY OF THESE FOOD ACCESSORIES
ARE MADE OF PLASTIC AND PLASTIC
PRODUCTION ADMITS GREENHOUSE
GASES AND HARMS INDIVIDUALS AND
COMMUNITIES. NEAR OLD
REFINERIES PLASTIC PRODUCTION
FACILITIES AND LANDFILLS OR
INCINERATORS THE INCREASING
SURGE IN THE USE OF MATERIALS
EXACERBATES HEALTH RISKS
PREDOMINATELY. IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES LIKE THE ONE I
REPRESENTED ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
FIFTY ONE. I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THIS VERY
CRITICAL ISSUE WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH ME IN MY OFFICE
AND STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THREE OF US AND A FEW OTHERS
THAT'LL GET YOUR GET HIT THE
NAMES ON. TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR AVAILABLE TO TESTIFY IS
BECCA MARTIN WHO IS A SENIOR
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS WITH GRUBHUB. AND
EMILY PARKER THE COASTAL MARINE
SCIENCE WITH THE COASTAL AND
MARINE SCIENTISTS WITH HEAL THE
BAY AND REUSABLE ALLEY. THAT IS
REQUIRED BY. I'M. JUST TO
CLARIFY- PRIOR TO OUR
CONVERSATION THIS MORNING WE'RE
ACCEPTING. YOU'RE ALSO I MEAN
IF YOU LOOK AT THE AND SO I
PERSONAL PRITCHETT YOU EXCEPT
IN THE MEMONS. I GUESS AT THE
BOTTOM OF PAGE EIGHT TOP OF
PAGE NINE WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE- THE COMMON ITEMS
YOU'RE ACCEPTING EACH OF THE
ONES THAT ARE MISSING SUFFER
COUPLET IS THAT CORRECT. AND
WHAT WE ARE ACCEPTING THE
DEFINITION OF UTENSILS TO
INCLUDE KNIFES FORKS. FORKS
RADOMES IN ADDITION TO HOT
SAUCE IN THE CONDIMENT. THOSE
ARE IT. WELL OKAY EXTRA HOT
INCLUDED CHARM. I WOULD LET'S
LET'S GO AHEAD AND WHETHER
THERE WAS AN IMMINENT THE
BOTTOM PIECE NINETY BUT LET'S
GO AHEAD AND TAKE THE REST OF
THE TESTIMONY BUT MAYBE IN THE
MEANTIME. WE CAN JUST. SHARE
THE CENTER THIS THIS THAT
LANGUAGE WITH YOU TO MAKE SURE
YOU REMEMBER- DIDN'T WE GET TO
SEE WHAT'S THE WHAT'S YOUR
ANALYSIS AND THEM AND WE CAN.
GET THAT CLARIFIED AS- AS THE
AS THE AS THE HEARINGS CONTINUE
SO LET'S GO TO YOUR- SUPPORT
WITNESS THIS IS EMILY PARKER
FROM REUSABLE LA COALITION.
FOLLOWED BY AMY HEALY FROM-
GRAB. THIS MORNING EMILY PARKER
CAN YOU HEAR ME ALRIGHT. YES WE
CAN THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
MORNING SHALL ON COMMITTEE
ADDED TO THEM PARKER AND THE
COAST AND MARINE WHICH KILLED
BAY I WENT IN AND BY NON OR
BASED IN MONICA WHERE MEMBERS
THE GREEN THE LAW COLOR. ON
ASSEMBLY .COM SEVENTY. I'M ALSO
THE CO CHAIR OF THE REUSABLE L.
A. K. WE STAND IN THE POINT OF
IT BILL TALK ANYTHING AT THE
BUDGET IS A WIN ACROSS THE FOR
I'VE BEEN GOVERNMENT CAN YOU
AND IN. THE COMPANY AND BEGAN
THE WAYS CRAY WE WERE IN HOW
THE RAPIDLY YOU DEFINITELY
CLASSIC LAST YEAR ALONE
INCREASED UP 23100% A GREAT
PORTION OF THAT INCLUDES POCKET
COME FROM IMPOSSIBLE FOODS
WHERE. YOU'LL HAVE A BEACH
CLEANUP DATA FROM LAST YEAR
SHOWED THAT- ACCESSORIES
INCREASED IN RANKED AS THE
NUMBER FOUR MOST. COMMONLY
FOUND ITEM DURING OUR BETWEEN.
I'M FEELING RESTAURANT POINT I
HAVE ON OUT AND- JUST OPENED
THE PEN. THEY HAD NO OP BUT TO
YOU THE PHONE. HOWEVER AND
THERE IS OPTION SAVE MONEY CUT
ON WASTE ONLY. IT LIKE YOU CAN
AND KIND OF AND A CUSTOMER.
ASKED HIM ON ANGELES WE HAVE
OUR MAN. PASSED WE WOULD OUT
THREE ON A QUEST ORDINANCES
THAT BOTH THE CITY AND THE
COUNTY LEVEL. IN RECENT WEEKS
WE HAVE CONDUCTED OVER THE PAST
SIX MONTHS. EVERY SINGLE
RESTAURANT WE SPOKEN WITH
CLINTON STRONG SUPPORTER OF
THIS LEGISLATION. WE COLLECTED
OVER THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED
PETITION SIGNATURES FROM
ANGELENOS ACROSS THE COUNTY.
AND GARNERED THOUSAND WRITTEN
COMMENTS EMAILS THE PHONE CALLS
AND TWEETS OF SUPPORT. DALY
CITY. COUNCIL AND ALLIE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS. THESE CAME FROM
RATHER THAN LOCAL BUSINESSES
AND AFTER. AND MY MOM ORGANISE.
AND EVEN IF THE LAKE CHAMBER
COMMERCE. THIS WHAT IN JUST TO
SHOW HOW NEED THIS BUT- IN ON A
PER. STATEWIDE. I'VE BEEN SO
THAT IN MY LAY AB TWO SEVENTY
CAN RESTAURANT THAT THREE
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE. DOLLARS A
YEAR AND DRASTICALLY. ONE AFTER
ANOTHER ANGELES PREDICT THAT
THIS ORDINANCE ALONE WILL SAVE
HIM FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
ANNUAL CAUGHT. MATT OPTION TO
SAVE MONEY AND CONSUMERS WANT
THAT OPTION SO THEY NO LONGER
RECEIVE ITEMS THAT THEY DON'T
WANT OR NEED. BENEFIT CONSUMERS
AND OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT ALL
AGREED THAT BY DEFLATION IN A
WIN WIN WIN PLEASE VOTE AYE ON
AB TWELVE SEVENTY SIX AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
AND WHEN. DONE WITH THIS
PROBLEM. YEAH ALL RIGHT.
GONZALEZ MATTER CAN YOU HAVE
THE NEXT PERSON PRESENT PLEASE.
ASSEMBLY FROM GRUBHUB. ENNIS'S
MODERATOR CAN I GET YOUR NAME
AGAIN PLEASE. THAT WOULD BE
EMILY PARKER I'M SORRY NOW
THAT'S THE BIGGEST MARTIN AMY
HUGHEY AMY HEALY HEAD OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS AND PUBLIC
POLICY FROM CRAFT ALONG THE
COAST FROM LINE. IF THEY'RE NOT
AVAILABLE WE CAN GO BACK TO
THEM BUT- YEAH THEY HAVE THEY
HAVE THAT TALENT OKAY WHEN WE
GO TO. TO FOLKS ONE OF WAY IN
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE LINES.
MISTER CHAIR I THINK WE HAVE
BECCA MARTIN ON THE LINE WITH
GRUBHUB. OKAY. SEVEN MARTIN MRS
MARTIN MISTER MARTIN BAKER IT
IS MISS MARTIN AVAILABLE FOR
GROWTH OF MODERATOR I'M A CO
HOST FROM NINE. I DO NOT SEE
THEM DIALED IN ALL RIGHT LET'S
GO AHEAD AND TAKE TESTIMONY
FROM A SORRY FOR FOLKS ONE
VOICE SUPPORT ON THE PHONE
LINES. FROM THE GENERAL PUBLIC.
CERTAINLY THIS IS YOUR MIND IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AND- FIRST IN
LINE FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS WENDY
REYNOLDS FROM CALIFORNIA VISORS
ON BEHALF OF UBER EATS IN
SUPPORT. AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NUMBER JENNIFER HEARING ON
BEHALF OF OCEANIA AND OCEAN
CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT. AND IT
WILL TO LINE SIXTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING HERE
NUMBER IS PREFERRED YOU DON'T
ON BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING
CLIENT CALIFORNIA PRODUCT WHICH
ACCOUNTABLE FITTING COUNTY SAN
FRANCISCO CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS. NATIONAL SOLUTIONS
ACTION CAMPBELL STOCK WAIT.
WAIT IS THE VISION OF NORTH
AMERICA ALLEGE THAT A TASK
FORCE AND WHAT TO DO WITH
MANAGEMENT AUTHORITY ALL. IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NATURAL TO
LINE FIFTY FIVE ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO
LINE SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING AMERICA
MADELINE COOPER FROM NIELSEN
MARKS WERE ON BEHALF OF MARIN
COUNTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOUNG.
SIX THANKS A LOT ONLINE SEVENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
SHANNON CURVING ALONG WITH
ROBIN'S RESTAURANT MANAGEMENT
CRAFT AND PALLACANESTRO AND
SUPPORT. THANKS THE LINE
SEVENTY FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN
EXCUSE ME PLEASE GO AHEAD. COME
MORNING CAROLINE IN MEMBERS
GENEVIEVE ADDED ON ON BEHALF OF
THE CLEAN HE'S LOBBYING
COALITION PROUDLY SPONSORING
THIS BILL WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO AND WE THANK THE MEMBER
FOR ALL OF ALL OF YOUR WORK
WITH THAT AND ALL THE OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS ON WORKING THROUGH
LANGUAGE ON THE CELL. AND THANK
YOU CHALLENGE FOR CO AUTHORING
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANKS A LOT
ONLINE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE BALKANS OFFICE
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
THOUSAND OAKS AND SUPPORT. HOLD
ON THE LINE SIXTY SEVEN SIX
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. CURRENT
MEMBERS DON'T COME ALONG IN THE
HOPE OF THE CALIFORNIA COMPOST
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ON THE LINE FORTY
SEVEN FOUR SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M TURNED UP AND BURKE
CHEN MILAN'S NURSES FOR HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENTS AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. WE'LL
GO TO LINE THIRTY THREE ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS YOUR
LAYER THE FROM CAN COLLECTION
LOS ANGELES AND ORANGE STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE SEVENTY
SIX WHICH WILL HELP CALIFORNIA
CUT CUTLERY. ANGLETON LINE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
HAVE THE LAST WORD FROM HABIT
THE WASTE LOS ANGELES CLEAR AND
STRONG SUPPORT THIS WILL HELP
YOU CUT CALORIES. BOUILLON IN
LITTLE LINE SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALLEN MEMBERS
MY NAME AT ME HELLO THERE AND
ON BEHALF OF THE THIRD BETTER
CONDITION WE ARE STRONG SUPPORT
AB TWELVE SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU.
THANKS A LITTLE LINE SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BREANNA
CONNECTICUT ON BEHALF OF WILL
BE THINK LEAST AND BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS AND
SUPPORT. WE WILL BUILD TO LINE
EIGHTEEN ONE EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE MORNING MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BECCA
MARTIN AND I AM HEAD OF STATE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR
GRANDPA I'M HERE TODAY TO
EXPRESS GRUBHUB THE CARD FOR AB
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CORREOS FAILED TO
REQUIRE DISPOSABLE FOOD WHERE
COUNTRIES BE MADE AVAILABLE
ONLY UPON REQUEST OF THE
CUSTOMER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO COMMITMENT TO
SUSTAINABILITY AND WE'RE
EXCITED TO SEE CALIFORNIA
CONFRONTING SUCH AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE HEAD ON. ON FEBRUARY
TWENTY FIFTH OF THAT YEAR
GRUBHUB OFFICIALLY JOINED THE
CUTOUT CUTLERY CAMPAIGN AND
COMMITTED TO DRAMATICALLY
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF SINGLE
USE PLASTICS THAT ENTER THE
ENVIRONMENT. IN THE COMING
MONTHS GRUBHUB APP AND WEBSITE
WILL BEGIN AUTOMATICALLY
DEFAULT DEFAULTING TO ZERO
UTENSILS AND NAPKINS WITH EVERY
ORDER. BOB DINERS WILL STILL BE
ABLE TO REQUEST PLASTIC WHERE
WE NEEDED THIS SMALL CHANGE
WILL GENERATE SIGNIFICANT
SUSTAINABILITY BENEFITS FOR
COMMUNITIES DINERS AND
RESTAURANTS. THIS ACTION WILL
REMOVE MILLIONS OF PIECES OF
PLASTIC CUTLERY FROM ENTERING
THE ENVIRONMENT ANNUALLY
ACCORDING TO HAVE THAT THE
VOICE .ORG ORGANIZER TO CUT OUT
COLOR CAMPAIGN FORTY BILLION
PIECES OF PLASTIC CUTLERY AND
UP IN THE WASTE STREAM EACH
YEAR. POLLUTING. OUR OCEANS AND
LITTERING OUR STREETS. BUT
BEYOND THE ENVIRONMENT BENEFITS
REMOVE CLASSIC WAY IT'S ANOTHER
WAY GROW. AND OUR DINERS CAN
CHEN COST. FOR ROSTRON AND- AT
A TIME WHEN THEY NEED IT MOST.
OUR THAT RESTAURANTS CAN
POTENTIAL THOUSANDS OF DOLLAR
ANNUALLY BY REDUCING THE AMOUNT
OF PLASTIC WHERE THEY
DISTRIBUTE. MUNICIPAL BUDGET
ALSO BENEFIT FROM THE REDUCTION
IN LETTER ON CITY STREETS.
USING OUR TECHNOLOGY PLATFORM
TO SUPPORT EFFORTS TO REDUCE
SINGLE USE PLASTIC WEIGHT IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP IN GRUBHUB'S
JOURNEY TOWARDS MORE
SUSTAINABLE BUSINESS PRACTICES
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO PARTNER WITH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE URGE
YOU TO VOTE IN FAVOR OF AB
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX AND MAKE
THESE CHANGES THE INDUSTRY.
INDUSTRY STANDARD THANK YOU.
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS CLARK BONTA ON BEHALF OF THE
RESOURCE RECOVERY COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA IN COURT. THE
MACHINE AN EXCELLENT ONLINE
SEVENTY EIGHT SEVEN EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS CHERYL HONORED
PRESIDENT OF JAPAN SINGLE USE
PLASTIC IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX YOU PREVENT
SINGLE USE PLASTIC WASTE. SHE'S
IN ORDER TO LINE TWELVE ONE TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
NANCY UP NOW IN A RESIDENT.
MEDIAN CALLING TRUMP AB TOLD
SEVENTY SIX CURRENTLY THERE ARE
FORTY BILLION PLASTIC EXAMPLE
THROWN AWAY EACH YEAR I GINGER
HABITS ABOUT BELIEVE CLASS THE
COLORS STATEWIDE ENFORCING
OFTEN OPTION FOR CONSUMERS WE
CAN REDUCE THAT NUMBER OF
PLASTIC. THE FAMILY SMALL
ACTIVE IN DISPOSABLE CUTLERY
CAN ADD UP TO BIG IMPACT ONE
RESTAURANT AND NOW THE STATE
GOVERNMENT STEPS UP TO SUPPORT
THE BILL AND CUT OUT CUTLERY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. AND
CONSIDERATION. AND WE WILL THE
LINE AT SEVEN NINE NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
MAKAYLA JARI CALLING IS SENATE
THEN FROM LOS ANGELES CA
SUPPORT AB ONE THOUSAND SIX
AFFECT CUT OUT COLOR. AND TO
CREATE BETTER HABITS WORLDWIDE.
AND A LITTLE LINE FIFTY FIVE
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING AGAIN HER NUMBER'S
NIKITA CROWDY WITH ENERGY
SEEKONK EIGHTY TWELVE SEVENTY
SIX THANK YOU. AND TO THE CHAIR
AND NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
AT THIS TIME. OPPOSITION. LET'S
TAKE OPPOSITION TESTIMONY WITH
REGARD TO THIS BILL AB TWELVE
SEVENTY SIX WE HAVE ONE LEAD
WITNESS THIS IS KATHY LYNCH
FROM THE AMERICAN FOREST AND
PAPER ASSOCIATION. GOOD MORNING
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES YES YOU
CAN. THANK YOU- THANK YOU
SENATOR ALLEN MEMBERS OF
COMMITTEE KATHLEEN LYNCH
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
FOREST AND PAPER ASSOCIATION
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSE MY
CEMENTED I'M NOT SURE ON ALL
THE AMENDMENTS THAT YOU'RE
TAKING SO MAYBE THIS ISSUE WILL
BE RESOLVED. FIRST I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS THEY HAVE BEEN ENGAGED
IN CONVERSATION WITH ME ABOUT
MY TECHNICAL REQUEST A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT PAPER RECYCLING
BECAUSE A LOT OF CONVERSATION
AROUND FIVE TODAY- PAPER IN
REACHED A SIXTY SIX POINT 2%
RECOVERY RATE- WE ARE FULLY
RECYCLING OUR MATERIALS YEAH
NOW BEEN THE NUMBER FROM TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN OR NAPKINS
WHICH ARE IN THE BILL ARE A
HUNDRED PERCENT- RECYCLED
CONTENT AND ARE CERTIFIED
COMPENSABLE. WE THINK THAT
NAPKIN- PROVIDE AN IMPORTANT
THE HYGIENIC AS WELL THEY ARE
IMPORTANT- VALUE TO USE- AND WE
WERE CONCERNED THAT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT COULD HAPPEN HERE
IS PEOPLE WELL THE FALCONS
CALLING OUT THOSE SINGLE WHITE
OUT OF THERE FOR WHICH- AS YOUR
COMMITTEE WELL KNOWS THAT GOT A
LOT OF ISSUES WHICH THAT THE
MEN OTHER. WORDS SEEKING
CLARIFICATION ON PAGE FIVE OF
THE BILL. BUT I'M WORKING ON IT
AND YET. THE SECTION. WHERE TO
YOU SEVEN ONE D. WHERE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT SELF SERVE- DOES
THAT YEAH YOUR HOW A NOW IN THE-
WE THINK THAT SHOULD BE RIGHT
ON ABOUT FOR THE CUSTOM. AND IT
SAYS BUT IN IN THE YOU'RE HONOR-
CONSUMER REQUEST SO THAT
WOULDN'T PROJECT SERVICE OR
ENACTING THE FENCE AND COULD BE
VERY UNSANITARY YEAH I DON'T
WHY THAT HAVE STOPPED AT THE
CASH REGISTER FROM OTHER
SITTING AT A TABLE WITH HER
KIDS REALIZE THIS YOU FORGOTTEN
OUT NOW AND NOW ABOUT THE PAPER
YEAH OR READ THEM UNATTENDED
AND TRY TO GO DOWN THE LINE TO
GET ON THAT YEAH. SO WE'RE JUST
ASKING FOR SOME. CLARIFICATION
ON THAT. NO WE HAVE NO OTHER
GROUPS ARE BUT BILL. THANK YOU
FOR THE- TO EXPRESS THAT. LET'S
HEAR FROM WITNESSES FROM FOLKS
WANT TO WEIGH IN IN OPPOSITION
TO RAISE CONCERNS WITH THE BILL
AB TWELVE SEVENTY SIX ON THE
PHONE LINES MODERATOR. THANK
YOU YEP NPR IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND ALLOW ME A FEW
MOMENTS TO THE JOURNAL COMMENTS
COMING IN.
DID YOU WANNA MAYBE
LET US KNOW LEADERS. ANYONE
SETTING ON AND IF IT. I JUST.
YEAH NO NO PUBLIC COMMENTS
COMING AND IN OPPOSITION OKAY
ALL RIGHT GREAT ALL RIGHT LET'S
BRING THE ITEM BACK TO THE-
COMMITTEE FOR DISCUSSION- MADAM
VICE CHAIR. HI JOHN I HAVE A
QUESTION REGARDING THE NAPKINS
BECAUSE I KNOW THE DRIVE THRU
RESTAURANTS OFTEN ASK YOU IF
YOU'RE CONSUMING IT IN THE CAR
OR YOU'RE TAKING AT HOME SO-
EAT IF IDENTIFIED AS SOMEONE
EATING IN THE CAR SHOULDN'T THE
NOW CAN BE AUTOMATICALLY
PROVIDED. IN IT WOULD YOU BE
WILLING TO TAKE AN AMENDMENT IF
YOU HAVEN'T ALREADY I'M NOT
SURE WHAT AMENDMENTS YOU ALL
ARE DISCUSSING. BECAUSE OF THIS
I KNOW ONE RESTAURANT IN
PARTICULAR I THINK IT'S IN N.
OUT BURGER THAT SHOULD STOP.
AUTOMATIC QUESTION NOW AND SHE
HAS YOU IN THE LINE. THAT TO IF
YOU'RE CONSUMING IN THE CAR
THEY IMMEDIATELY PUT BILLS IN
HAND TO EUROPE. INTO YOUR BAG
AND AYE NAPKINS AS MENTIONED BY
THE. OPPOSITION AS PART OF THE
SAN BEING. SENATOR AND IN THE
CAR SO WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS
ON THAT ASSUME WOMAN COULD RE.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION IT'S
THE OPT AND SO YOU ARE IN THE
CAR YARD AND OUT WHICH IS A
GREAT CALIFORNIA BUSINESS THE-
THE DRIVE THRU ATTENDANT IS
pCATCH UP DO YOU WANT THE LITTLE
YELLOW PEPPERS WHICH I LOVE D.
MONSTROSITY WANT NAPKINS ARE
YOU EATING IN THE CAR SO THAT'S
ALREADY AN OPT IN MODEL IN THE
BILL THEY WILL BE RECEIVING
THEIR NAPKINS WITH SO. WE JUST
WE JUST NEED TO REMIND BE
REMINDED THEM THAT LIST OF
THINGS THAT MAKE SURE THAT THE-
MAP CAN BE FOUND HERE OKAY
THANK YOU. OKAY SENATOR WHAT'S
GONNA. HI PREPARED TO MOVE THE
BILL AND- A CHAIR. I BELIEVE
THERE'S SOME AMENDMENTS YES SO-
SO WE'VE DISCUSSED SO SHE'S
ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENTS WHICH
ARE THE LANGUAGE AND BOLD ON
PAGE NINE PAGES NINE AND TEN.
I'M YOU KNOW. WE CLARIFIED
INITIALLY RELATING TO SOME OF
THE LANGUAGE OF THE BOTTOM OF
PAGE EIGHT WHICH AND SHE'S NOT
TAKING I WILL SAY- YOU KNOW I
KNOW THE CASE A COUPLE IT'S FOR
EXAMPLE. IT MAKES TOTAL SENSE
TO HAVE A COUPLE IT WHEN YOU'RE
ON THE GO. GET YOUR CAR WITH
HOT COFFEE. HOWEVER I WILL SAY
THERE A LOT OF SITUATIONS WHERE
PEOPLE ARE FOR SOME REASON
STARBUCKS AND OTHERS ARE GIVING
OUT DISPOSABLE CUPS FOR FOLKS
WHO ARE. TO GET A COPY AT THE
SHOP. AND IF YOU'RE LITERALLY
JUST GOING AND TO TABLE AT THE
SHOP IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THE
COUPLE IS KIND OF SILLY AND
WASTEFUL BUT- YEAH I UNDERSTAND
THAT- IT'S HARD TO WRITE THIS
IN A WAY THAT- CAN
DIFFERENTIATE IT WOULD
CERTAINLY BE MY PREFERENCE FOR
THEM THOSE KINDS OF SITUATIONS
FOR- FOR THE FOR THE BILL TO
APPLY- BUT- I UNDERSTAND I'M
NOT. I'M I'M NOT CERTAINLY NOT
GOING TO FORCE THAT ON TO THE
AUTHOR. OF THE OTHER ISSUE WE
WERE DISCUSSING WAS ISSUE
THAT'S MENTIONED ANALYSIS ON
PAGE NINE. IN SECTION FIVE. I
WHICH HAS TO DO WITH THE
PENALTY IN THE EXTENT TO WHICH
THE PENALTY IS. ADEQUATE TO
COVER THE ENFORCEMENT. COSTS
AND THE OTHER WAS MENTIONING
THAT THIS IS IN LINE WITH THE-
PERSONALITY ASSOCIATED WITH THE
STRAW- ORDINANCES AS ARE THE
STRONG LAW THAT- THAT- IN
DECEMBER CALDERON RAN A FEW
YEARS AGO- BUT IT DOES CONTINUE
TO BE A CONCERN OF MINE THAT-
WE ENSURE THAT. THAT- THERE'S
REAL THERE'S TEETH HERE HAVE.
YOU KNOW SOMETHING SOMETHING
FOR THE FOR THE FOR FOLKS TO
CONSIDER AS THIS BILL MOVES
ALONG. THOSE ARE THE THOSE ARE
THE AYE THOSE ARE THE ISSUES
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
REMEMBER THAT SHE HAS
UNEQUIVOCALLY ACCEPTED ARE THE-
ONES IN BOLD. ON PAGE NINE TEN.
MINUTES AUTHORS ACCEPTED AND I
JUST- I'VE COUPLE COMMENTS SO
TO MAKE BUT I AM INTERESTED-
WAS THE REMOVAL OF THE HIGHER.
IN NINETEEN. THE REMOVAL OF THE
HIGHER FINE. IT SAYS IN THE
ANALYSIS THE BILL REGIONALLY
HAD A ONE HUNDRED DOLLAR PER
DAY FINE WITH A MAXIMUM PENALTY
OF THOUSAND- DID YOU REMOVE
THAT YOURSELF OR DID WAS THAT
REQUIRED IN THE COMMITTEE IN
THE ASSEMBLY. I REMOVE THAT
MYSELF I BELIEVE THERE'S A
COUPLE OF THINGS THAT I WANT TO
ADDRESS WHEN IT COMES TO THE
FEES ONE THE TWENTY FIVE DOLLAR
FEE LINE. FINE YES THE TWENTY
FIVE DOLLAR FINE IS IN
ALIGNMENT WITH LEGISLATION
ALREADY PASSED THAT EXPANDS
THAT IS PART OF THE EXPANSION
OF THIS BILL WHICH IS THE
STRAW- LEGISLATION AUTHORED BY
FORMER MAJORITY LEADER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON- IN ADDITION TO
I ALSO WANT TO MAKE THE PROCESS
IN WHICH THESE FINES AND-
INSPECTIONS OCCUR TO BE
SEAMLESS. SO IF YOU ARE AN
INSPECTOR GOING INTO A
RESTAURANT AND YOU ARE SEEN
THAT STROSS ARE BEING
DISTRIBUTED- IT SHOULD BE IN
ALIGNMENT THERE'S A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN A STRONG ENOUGH WORK.
THERE'S NO REASON WHY WE WILL
CHARGE A RESTAURANT MORE FOR A
FOR A FORK R A KNIFE OR SPOON
VERSUS A STRAW I ALSO WANT TO
BE VERY CONSCIENTIOUS THAT WE
ARE. IN A RECOVERY MODE OF
FOLLOWING A GLOBAL PANDEMIC IN
WHICH ARE SMALL BUSINESSES AND
SMALL RESTAURANTS MOM AND POP
SHOPS ARE SIMPLY TRYING TO
RECOVER. SO LET'S DO THIS THE
WAY IT IS NOW LET'S TEST IT
LET'S SEE HOW IT WORKS AND IF
WE NEED TO COME BACK AND SEE
THAT THE YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY THE
LAW IS NOT BEING FOLLOWED THEN
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO
THAT. BUT I WANT TO ENSURE THAT
WE ARE MOVING FORWARD A PIECE
OF LEGISLATION THAT IS CLIMATE
ORIENTED THAT IS ENVIRONMENT
ORIENTED WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
ALLOWING SMALL BUSINESSES TO BE
ABLE TO ONE RECOVER AND TO PUT
THIS PRACTICE AND TO PLACE- I
SURE SIMILAR CONCERNS TO THE-
CHAIR. REGARDING IMPACT OF THE
PARTICULAR FINE- BUT-
APPRECIATE YOUR EXPLANATION
AND- WE PRICE SHOULDN'T BETTER
ON STRAWS BUT WHATEVER BUT I
MEAN THIS IS THE KIND OF THING
WHERE WERE OBVIOUSLY. WE ARE
HOPING THAT NOT ONLY SMALL
BUSINESSES RESTAURANTS BUT ALSO
THE PUBLIC. THROUGH LEGISLATION
LIKE THIS TAKES THE AWARENESS
TO- YOU KNOW NOT ALWAYS USE THE
SINGLE USE DISPOSABLE PRODUCTS
I HAVE TO- I APPRECIATE THIS
LEGISLATION BECAUSE DURING THIS
PANDEMIC IT HAS BEEN EXTREMELY
FRUSTRATING TO ME THAT. WHEN I
DID ORDER TO GO EVEN WHEN I
EXPLICITLY INDICATED SINCE I
WAS GOING TO EAT THE FOOD AT MY
HOME THAT I DIDN'T NEED ANY OF
THE FIGHT THOSE ITEMS I DIDN'T
NEED THE NAPKINS I DIDN'T NEED
ANY OF THE CUTLERY I WOULD GET
IT ANYWAY. AND OF COURSE RIGHT
HERE IN THIS BUILDING EVERY
TIME WERE SERVED LUNCH WE ARE
GIVEN THESE DISPOSABLE PACKAGES
OF DISPOSABLE CUTLERY NOW
IRONICALLY WHEN I WAS TALKING
TO A NUMBER OF THE FOOD
BUSINESSES IN MY AREA IN THE
IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC THEY SET
THE SINGLE LARGEST COST TO THEM
IN GOING RETURN CLEARLY TO GO
FOOD. WAS THOSE PACKETS THOSE
CUTLERY PAT PACKETS WHICH OF
COURSE YOU KNOW WHO KNOWS WHAT
PERCENT WERE DEAD NEVER USED
RIGHT AND- SO AND OF COURSE THE
IMPLICATIONS NOT ONLY MEAN
WASTEFUL THERE'S NO ONE AT THE
GROUND WASTE BUT THERE'S VERY
SERIOUS IMPLICATIONS AS THE
AUTHORS POINT OUT THE NOTICES
POINTED OUT. IN TERMS OF OUR
WATER OUR WATER WAYS OUR
LANDFILLS. OUR I MEAN JUST- I
NEED TO GO INTO MORE DETAIL OF
THE AMOUNT OF. OF ENERGY THAT
IS REQUIRED TO PRODUCE THESE
PRODUCTS AND THEN TO- DISPOSE
OF THEM. AND THEN BASICALLY
MOST OF THEM OTHER THAN THE
PAPER ONES ARE WITH US FOREVER.
SO I THINK THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT- MOVE. AND- I LIKED
IT THE ANALYSIS POINTED OUT AS
I DID IN THE EARLIER BILL THAT-
THE THREE R'S R. REDUCE REUSE
RECYCLE RECYCLE IS THE LAST OF
THE THREE R'S REDUCES THE FIRST
AND THIS IS MORE IN THE
DIRECTION OF REDUCED SO- AGAIN
I MOVE THE BILL AS AMENDED.
THANK YOU FOR THE SENS CARE.
OKAY BOB YES AND ONLY. I LIKE
TO FOLLOW UP ON CENTER
SKINNER'S COMMENT ON SO LIKE WE
DO AS WE GET OUR SALADS HERE TO
CAPITOL THEY COME WITH THE-
WITH THE- SOULPEPPER. IT'S ALL
WRAPPED UP IN THE PLUS THINGS
INSIDE THE- SALAD CONTAINERS SO.
WHO WHO'S THAT'S NOT GOING TO
BE IN THERE ANYMORE UNLESS WE
ASK FOR RIGHT SO I GUESS I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT I THINK
THERE'S GONNA BE A LOT OF
CONFUSION BY WHO'S- WHO'S
SUPPOSED TO DO WHAT. AND SO IN
AND OUT THE OTHER THING IS THAT
BUSINESS RIGHT NOW. AS YOU
STATED. IS BEEN STRUGGLING TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT ALL THE RULES
THERE'S DINING IN DINING OUT
THERE'S- CAN WEAR MASKS NOT
MEANS LOTS OF CONFUSION AND
SPECIALLY IN THIS INDUSTRY IN
THE FOOD INDUSTRY. WERE THERE'S
A LOT OF FRUSTRATION I WOULD
SAY SO. I'M NOT SURE OF THE
TIMING OF THIS BILL IS A GREAT
IDEA I GUESS I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO CURB. WE'RE TRYING TO
ADD WE'RE TRYING TO. GET THE
PUBLIC TO BE AWARE OF THE FACT
THAT. IF YOU DON'T NEED IT
DON'T YOU DON'T HAVE TO HAVE IT
I GET I UNDER. I TOTALLY GET
THAT- SO. WHERE WHERE IS THE
WHO'S IT LIABLE THAT POINT.
LIKE IF. WE DON'T NEED. TO I
HAVE A FORK IN MY OFFICE THAT I
USE AND I DON'T NEED TO AND
HAVE SALT AND PEPPER AND A
NAPKIN. WHO WHO'S WHO'S LIABLE
WHAT WHO'S WHO'S AT FAULT.
THANKS FOR THAT QUESTION CENTER
I THINK IT WOULD DEPEND ON
WHERE YOU GET YOUR SALAD FROM
SO THIS IS SPECIFICALLY TO
RESTAURANT SO WHETHER YOU GET
YOUR SALAD FROM BALK AT A
GROCERY STORE VERY DIFFERENT
THEN YOU'RE GOING TO A LOCAL
RESTAURANT TO BE ABLE TO
RECEIVE- YOUR FOOD WHETHER IT'S
YOU BINA DIRECTLY OR WHETHER
YOU'RE ORDERING IT THROUGH A
THIRD PARTY APP WHICH HAS THE
OPTIONS TO. GET THE COMMENTS
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
WHETHER IT'S A FORK OR SALT AND
PEPPER SO IT JUST DEPENDS THIS
IS NOT INCLUDE- GROCERY STORES
SO IF THIS IS IF YOU'RE BUYING
LIKE A ALREADY PREMADE SALAD
OUTSIDE YOUR LOCAL GROCERY
STORE THIS IS. NOT THAT WERE
SPECIFICALLY TALKING ABOUT
WHETHER YOU ARE GOING INSIDE A
RESTAURANT WHETHER YOU ARE
TAKING WHETHER YOU GO INSIDE
THE RESTAURANT EAT THERE
WHETHER YOU ARE GOING INSIDE
THE RESTAURANT AND TAKING IT TO
GO. OR WHETHER YOU ARE IN A
DRIVE THROUGH. OKAY. OKAY ARE
LESS THE BILLS A MOVE BY CENTER
SKINNER I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
THE BILL AND IF IT IS
ULTIMATELY JUST ABOUT. GIVING
CONSUMERS THE OPTION. IF THEY
WANT TO USE THESE PRODUCTS ARE
NOT AND IN SO MANY CASES
THEY'RE GIVING THESE PRODUCTS
IN A WIN WHEN THEY- WHEN THEY
ACTUALLY HAVE NO USE FOR THEM-
FIRST FOR THE- FIRST FOR THE
FOR CONSUMING THEM. YEAH BOB
I'VE GONE MANY TIMES BROUGHT
EXACTLY THE EXAM EXPERIENCES OF
CENTER SKINNER WHERE I WANT TO
SUPPORT A LOCAL BUSINESS. AND
GET TAKE OUT THOMAS WAS
EVERYWHERE DON'T WANT ALL THE
STUFF THAT I DON'T NEED TO
BECAUSE I'M GOING TO COME HOME
AND EAT IT WITH MY FAMILY HOME
I GOT PLENTY OF NICE CALORIES
YET THERE THERE IT IS- MY OF A
BAG FULL OF PLASTICS- THAT I'M
NOT GONNA THAT I'VE KNOWN NO
USE FOR. SOME ARE VERY MUCH OF
THE PROJECT THE SPAWNING I'M
GONNA THROW IN SUPPORT OF TODAY
SO TO MOVE BY SENATOR- CONSULT
PLEASE COLOR. MAKE MY CLOTHES.
HELLO I'M SO SORRY I'M SO SORRY.
YES OF COURSE THANK YOU M. LET
ME JUST REITERATE- THAT I THINK
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
PROVISIONS AND AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE TAKING IN THIS BILL THANKS
TO THE WORK DONE BY THE
COMMITTEE- STAFF AND LET ME
READ IT IT SAYS ALL FOOD
FACILITIES ARE ENCOURAGED BUT
NOT REQUIRED TO TAKE ACTIONS IN
ADDITIONS TO THE REQUIREMENTS
OF THIS SECTION THAT SUPPORTS
THE GOAL OF REDUCING THE USE.
OF AND WASTE GENERATED BY ALL
SINGLE USE FOODSERVICE PRODUCTS
AND I WANT TO SAY THAT BECAUSE
MISTER TERRY YOUR COMMENTS
ABOUT RECEIVING THE LETTER NOT-
ON A COFFEE CUP I REMEMBER I
RECALL IN THE NINETIES WHEN
COFFEE SHOPS BECAME. REALLY
COOL AND EVERYBODY WANTED TO
HANG OUT AT A COFFEE SHOP YOU
GOT YOUR COFFEE IN A MUG. WE
HAVE GONE AWAY FROM THAT AND
NOW YOU'RE GETTING THAT YOUR
COFFEE CUP IN ANY CONTAINER TO
GO I WISH IN OUR CONVERSATION
THAT WE CAN GO BACK TO THE DAYS
WHERE IT WAS JUST THE COFFEE
SHOP OR WHATEVER HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WASH DISHES. AND
THAT'S PART OF THE SITUATION
INSTANCE NOT EVERYONE DOES AND
pCONVERSATION AS TO WHO AND
WHERE AND HOW AND SO I JUST I
THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
FOR THOSE THAT ARE ABLE TO HAVE
THE ABILITY TO WASH. REUSABLE
CUPS THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO AND
I HOPE THEY ARE ENCOURAGED TO
DO SO VERSES PERHAPS A SMALL
COFFEE SHOP THAT DOES NOT HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO BE ABLE TO USE
REUSABLE CUPS SO AGAIN JUST A-
I THINK A POINT OF
CLARIFICATION AS TO WHERE WE
HAVE BEEN IN THE PAST. WHERE WE
CAN GO IN THE FUTURE AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS PARTICULAR
AMENDMENT TO ENCOURAGE- A
BUSINESSES TO BE ABLE TO USE
REUSABLE SERVICE WHERE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE THEIR OWN
REDUCTION OF THEIR OWN COST- TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE AN AND
REALLY I THINK CURVE
CONSUMPTION IN A WAY THAT'S
MORE. ENVIRONMENTALLY FOCUSED
AND CONSCIENTIOUS OF OUR OWN
USE IN OUR OWN WASTE- HERE IN
THE STATE AND HOPEFULLY MAKE AN
IMPACT ACROSS THE COUNTRY SO
AGAIN I THANK YOU FOR THE
ROBUST CONVERSATION THE
CONTINUED COM. I THINK THIS IS
A STEP FORWARD THAT WE ALSO GET
TO REVISIT IN THE FUTURE AND
SEE HOW IT GOES I'M- I'M
PARTICULARLY JUST ALSO VERY.
CONSCIENTIOUS OF THE IMPACT
THAT WE HAVE ON SMALL
BUSINESSES AS THEY RECOVER.
RIGHT NOW WE MAY BE RECEIVING
MULTIPLE THINGS WRAPPED IN
PLASTIC. BUT IT ISN'T BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT THE BUSINESSES WANT
TO DO BUT IT'S BECAUSE WE'VE
BEEN LIVING THROUGH COVERED.
AND EVERYTHING HAS BEEN SUPER
CLEAN AND EXTRA PROTECTIONS.
HOPEFULLY THAT GETS THE CHANGE
IN THE FUTURE. SO AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR THE CONVERSATION AB
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP IN REDUCING
WASTE. I THINK A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION- I LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION
WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND THOSE
INTERESTED. AND ULTIMATELY AT
THE END OF THE DAY. REDUCER OUR
CONSUMPTION OF SINGLE USE
PLASTIC AND SINGLE USE OF FOOD
ACCESSORIES. AND WITH THAT I
RESPECT YOUR QUESTION ABOUT.
TOPICAL. NUMBER FOUR AB TWELVE
SEVENTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CARILLO THE MOTION IS DUE
PROCESS DO PASSED AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST. DO PASSED AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE. SENATOR ALAN ALLEN AYE
BATES DALI DALI NO GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I SKINNER SKINNER AYE
STERN AYE STERN AYE MICHALSKI
BY THE COUNTYON. NAPSTER OKAY
THE BOOK THAT BILL HAS THE
VOTES AGAIN AFTER WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE TO FOR FOLKS TO ALLEN
THANK YOU THE DECEMBER ISSUE IT.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE NEXT GOING TO
GO TO CECILIA AGUIAR-CURRY
WHO'S HERE TO PRESENT ITEM TWO
ON YOUR AGENDA MEMBERS THIS IS
A- A. B. TEN EIGHTY SIX.
RECEIVE IN WRITING. THE. I
GUESS IT'S FAIR TO SAY GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS FIRST AND
FOREMOST I'D LIKE TO THANK YOUR
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS. AB TEN
EIGHTY SIX REQUIRES A NATURAL
RESOURCE AGENCY TO COORDINATE
WITH CAL EPA TO RECOMMEND A
COORDINATED STRATEGY. BUT BUILT
REDUCING EMISSIONS ASSOCIATED
WITH FORESTRY AGRICULTURE AND
URBAN ORGANIC WASTE. REDUCING
WILDFIRE LANDFILLING PILE
BURNING OF ORGANIC WASTE ACROSS
SECTORS IS CRITICAL TO MEETING
OUR EXISTING CLIMATE AND AIR
QUALITY NEEDS AND GOALS.
HOWEVER THE STATE LACKS A
COORDINATED STRATEGY AND
FUNDING PLANNED TO MAXIMIZE THE
BENEFICIAL REUSE OF THESE
ORGANIC MATERIALS. BENEFICIAL
RE USE SUCH AS COMPOST BIO
ENERGY OR SOIL AMENDMENTS CAN
SUPPORT NET CARBON CARBON
EMISSION REDUCTIONS IMPROVED
AIR QUALITY AND OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
BENEFITS. A STRATEGIC PLAN ON
ORGANIC WASTE MANAGEMENT WILL
PROVIDE LONG TERM TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL AND DATA INFORM
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO
SUPPORT INCENTIVIZE THE
BENEFICIAL RE USE OF ORGANIC
WASTE. IT WILL CONSIDER AND
BALANCE IMMEDIATE NEEDS OF
LOCAL COMMUNITIES
DISPROPORTIONATELY EXPOSED TO
ENVIRONMENTAL POLLUTION
INCLUDING WILD FIRE SMOKE. WITH
ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT ARE
JUST SOME A LOT OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMPOSTS COALITION
AND JULIE ELEVEN OF THE
CALIFORNIA BIOENERGY
ASSOCIATION. THE RIVERS UNITY
MISTER MONTE. SECURA MEMBERS
THANK YOU AND THANKS TO THE OLD
ADDRESS ALONG THE BOX OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMPOSED COALITION
WITH THE COMMERCIAL COMPOSTERS
THAT HANDLE THE BULK OF THIS
ORGANIC MATERIAL AND CONVERT IT
INTO A POSITIVE PRODUCT THIS IS
A LONG- THE JEW I WANTED DON'T
MINCE MY WORDS I WE WAITED FIVE
YEARS FOR AB AT TEN FORTY FIVE
TO COME UP WITH SOMETHING WE
DON'TNEED ANOTHER REPORT. WE
NEED DOESN'T MINISTRATION TO
RALLY ALL ITS FORCES TO BRING
ITS DEPARTMENTS TOGETHER
CALIFORNIA CDFA CAL RECYCLE
CALTRANS AND DEPARTMENT OF
ENERGY EVERYBODY AND. COME UP
WITH A COMPREHENSIVE. HOLD
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN NOT ANOTHER
ROUTE I THINK THE OLDER KERR IT
INSISTING THAT THIS BE DONE WE
HAVE THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
GOING TO BE PUTTING ENFORCED
WITHIN SIX MONTHS AND THE STATE
DOESN'T HAVE A PLAN IT DOESN'T
HAVE TO HELP THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND THE VERY VERY
MODEST BUDGET APPROPRIATIONS OF
SIXTY FIVE MILLION ISRAELI NOT
GONNA CUT IT WHEN WE GOT
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
INVESTMENT TO MAKE IN ORDER TO
MEET OUR CLIMATE AND RESOURCE
GOALS SO WE HAVE PROBABLY ALL
HAPPEN DURING THIS A GAME WE
NATURAL RESOURCES OF THE NEED.
BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING TO SEE
THIS TO BE MORE HOLISTIC THAN
JUST A REGULATORY RESPONSE BUT
THAT BEING SAID WE A 100%
SUPPORT THE BILL AND HOPE THAT.
YOU CAN SUPPORT IT TOO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU COULD YOU ELEVEN
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON TO WE
ARE LEFT ONLY WITH A BIOENERGY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WE TO
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TEN EIGHTY
SIX CALIFORNIA HAS PASSED A LOT
OF LAWS AND POLICIES IN THE
PAST FEW YEARS TO ADDRESS AGAIN
EQUATION ISSUES CONNECTICUT
SENATE BILL NINE A ONE AND A
FOR STEWARDSHIP AGREEMENT
ENTERED INTO WITH THE U. S.
FOREST SERVICE. THAT WILL
CREATE TEN TO FIFTEEN MILLION
BONE DRY TONS OF COURSE REYES
AND OTHER VEGETATION TO REDUCE
WILDFIRE RISKS AIRBOARD
RECENTLY ADOPTED A PLAN TO
PHASE OUT THE OPEN BURNING
AGRICULTURAL WASTE BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE THAT TO CALLS FOR
MORE BIO ENERGY AND OTHER
ALTERNATIVES TO OPEN BERNIE.
SANDERS DUSTIN MENTIONED SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
REQUIRES THAT WE DIVERT FIFTEEN
MILLION TONS OF ORGANIC
LANDFILL WASTE EACH AND EVERY
YEAR WE ALSO HAVE TO REDUCE
METHANE FROM DAIRIES AND BLACK
CARBON FROM THE OPEN BURNING OF
FOREST AG WASTE. CONVERTING ALL
OF THIS ORGANIC WASTE TO ENERGY.
ORGANIC SOIL AMENDMENT. BY AND
OTHER AND YOU CAN PROVIDE HUGE
BENEFITS TO CAL. INCLUDING ROCK
INTO WITH KIND POLLUTING.
WILDFIRE MITIGATION BLOCKS AND
ERICA. AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
NEW JOBS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IN EVERY REGION OF
THE STATE. BUT TO ACHIEVE THESE
BENEFITS WE NEED. VERY FOCUSED
SCIENCE BASED IMPLEMENTATION
PLAN THAT ENSURES THAT STATE
AGENCIES COORDINATE ACROSS WAY
SECTORS PUT ORGANIC WASTE TO
THE HIGHEST AND BEST USE REMOVE
REGULATORY BARRIERS AND
IDENTIFY THE FUNDING NEEDS AND
OPTIONS AVAILABLE. FOR ALL
THESE REASONS WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT AB TEN
EIGHTY SIX WHICH WILL ASK THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON SCIENCE
TECHNOLOGY TO DEVELOP THAT
SCIENCE BASED PLAN AND HELP THE
STATE A CHEAP URGENT CLIMATE
AIR QUALITY WASTE REDUCTION AND
WILDFIRE REDUCTION GOALS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THAT ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINES TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO VOICE.
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. THE V.
TEN EIGHTY SIX A SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL ONLY PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ANY TELEPHONE
KEYPAD AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND
THEN ZERO. WE WILL GO FIRST
LINE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
ALEXIS CHáVEZ CALLING ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
WASTE AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT IN LINE THIRTY SIX.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS NOT
A MOM- CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY LLIANCE AND
SUPPORT. ONE THIRTY EIGHT. MORE
FOR ON A ON BEHALF OF THE
RESOURCE RECOVERY COALITION OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. NINE
SEVENTY SEVEN ZERO. KELLY BOYD
COLIN GREENING COOPERATED AT
SIXTEEN OF ALL CLEAN ENERGY
PROVIDER IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NINE SIXTY SIX ZERO. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN VIRTUALLY
ALL THE DIGITIZATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. PINE EIGHTY
FOUR. AFTERNOON BRIDGET MCHALE
BEHALF OF RETHINK WASTE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO
OTHER LINES IN Q. FOUR SUPPORT
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT- I DON'T BELIEVE WE HAVE
ANY AND ANYONE WHO'S- QUEUED UP
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION AND I
ALSO DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S ANY
REGISTERED OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL BUT IS ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINES. OPERATOR WHO'D LIKE TO.
VOICE CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL.
THANK YOU TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL YOU MAY PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE
AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. THANK YOU KERN ALLIANCE
IN Q. THANK YOU LET'S BRING
THIS BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS ABOUT
SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU- THE
CHAIR AND I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS- THIS
IS THE ES YOU YOURSELF STATED
AND- YOUR KEY WITNESS WE NEED
THE STRATEGIC PLAN-
INTERESTINGLY MOST FOR
JURISDICTIONS AT SOME POINT OR
ANOTHER UNDER OUR REGIONAL-
WASTE REDUCTION BILL AB NINE
THIRTY NINE HAD TO DO WASTE
COMPOSITION ANALYSIS. AND THOSE
THAT HAD REALLY- ROBUST
RECYCLING PROGRAMS FOUND THAT
THEY WERE DOING A VERY GOOD JOB
REMOVING THINGS LIKE PAPER AND-
LIMON GLASS THINGS LIKE THAT
FROM THERE- WE STREAM WITH THE-
BIGGEST. THE LARGEST COMPONENT
THAT WAS STILL IN THEIR WASTE
STREAM IN THIS NO NO WE'RE NOT
TALKING PLASTICS RIGHT NOW BUT-
OTHERWISE. WAS ORGANIC WASTE.
AND SO WE NOW KNOW MANY MANY
JURISDICTIONS HAVE MOVED TO.
ORGANIC WASTE COLLECTION YOU
KNOW I FORTUNATELY I LIVE
SOMEWHERE WHERE I CAN HAVE BEEN
I CAN PUT ALL MY YARD CLIPPINGS
ALL MY DUTCH BOOKLET ALL MY
FOOD IN THAT BEEN. HOWEVER AT
SOME OF THE JURISDICTIONS THAT
HAVE SUCH FACILITIES THAT
SUPPORT OF WHAT I WAS SAYING
BEFORE PUTTING SOMETHING IN A
BIN. DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN
IT'S GOING TO GET. A UTILIZED
IN THE WAY THAT WE- INTENT SO
WILL IT IN FACT BE COMPOSTED
WILL IT. BE POTENTIALLY USED
FOR EXAMPLE FOR BIO ENERGY YOU
KNOW THOSE ARE NOT THE
GUARANTEES IT'S ONLY THAT YOU
CAN PUT IT IN A BIT IN THIS
STRATEGIC PLAN I THINK WILL
HELP GIVE US. THAT ROAD MAP
WHICH WE NEED BECAUSE ORGANIC
WASTE HAS A LOT OF VALUE YEAH-
SHOP I SUPPORT THE BILL AND I'M
OF IT YEAH THANK YOU I WAS
REMOVED BY CENTER SKINNER
SENATE DOLLY. I THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR THE BILL I WANT TO
JUST. HAVE JERRY KNOW THAT. I
AM A LITTLE CONCERNED- FONG. I
AGREE WITH WHAT THE SENATOR
FROM BERKELEY SAID ABOUT
ORGANIC WASTE IT'S 40% MORE
FOOD IS THROWN AWAY NUMBER ONE
WEEK WE ALL KNOW THAT WE NEED
TO BE COMPOSTING THAT WE NEED
TO BE PUTTING IT BACK INTO. OUR
SOILS QUITE FRANKLY. BUT WHEN
IT COMES TO BIOMASS IN LIKE
WOULD WASTE. THEN YOU KNOW WE-
WE RECYCLE. BOMBING HOLES WE
MAKE ENERGY OUT OF THOSE- BUT
WHEN WE LOOKED AT. WHAT THE
AIRBOARD DID WITH SB ONE
HUNDRED DATE SO SB ONE HUNDRED
PASSED AND THEY WERE SUPPOSED
TO DO IS COPING OF HOW SB IN.
FOUR HUNDRED BUT LOOK. IF YOU
READ THE REPORT. THERE THEY
THEY WENT FURTHER THAN WHAT S.
B. WHEN HER THEY THEY DON'T
LIKE COMBUSTION THEY DON'T LIKE
BURNING OF ANYTHING AND SO. I
JUST WANT TO CAUTION I THINK
THE MEMBERS THAT. IF YOU CAN DO
IT IN A CONTROLLED ENVIRONMENT.
AND ACTUALLY PRODUCE GREEN
ENERGY. THERE'S A IT'S A LOT
BETTER BENEFITS IN HAVING IT
BURNT OPEN OR EVEN COMPOST OPEN
BECAUSE YOU HAVE NOTHING THAT
COMES OUT. IN COMPANIES AND BY
THE WAY THERE'S A BY PRODUCT
TWO COMES OUT- BIO CHAR OR ASH
WHICH IS VERY. GOOD FOR THE
SOILS AS WELL. SO IT GOES FULL
CIRCLE FIVE JUST WANT TO SHARE
THAT THE DETAILS MATTER AND HOW
WE GET TO THE POINT WORK- THIS
REPORT COMES BACK WE ACTUALLY
START DOING IT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT ALL- AVAILABLE
TECHNOLOGY IN IF IT'S NOT. A
100% IF THE TECHNOLOGY ISN'T
THERE TO MEET THE GOALS OF THE
AMOUNT OF MATERIAL WE NEED TO.
RECYCLE OR REUSE OR- OR TAKE
THE VALUE OUT OF WE NEED TO
ALLOW THOSE. BIOMASS FACILITIES
THAT ACTUALLY BURN IT IN A
CONTROLLED ENVIRONMENT AND MAKE
ENERGY OUT OF IT BE USEFUL
BECAUSE WE'RE PUSHING WE'RE
MOVING TOWARDS NON COMBUSTION
THAT MEANS NO FIRE. AND I THINK
THAT'S FOR- VERY- I DON'T THINK
THE TECHNOLOGIES ARE MOVED
AMOUNT OF MATERIAL WE NEED
MISSUS I JUST WANT TO SHARE
THAT I'M GONNA BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY- BUT SOMEBODY
HAS REALLY WORKED IN THIS FIELD
A LOT TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
WE DO WITH. LITERALLY BILLIONS
OF TONS OF FOREST RESIDUE THAT
IS IN MY DISTRICT RIGHT NOW
EMITTING CARBON LIKE CRAZY
THERE'S THREE FIRES UP THERE
AND THEY'RE EXPANDING EVERY DAY
WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT THIS AND
WE NEED IT INTEL WE GET TO. A
HUNDRED PERCENT. WE CAN WE CAN
LET'S TAKE THE NINETY EIGHT AND
PUT IT THROUGH A- COGENERATION
PLANT AND MAKE ELECTRICITY OUT
OF AT LEAST SO I JUST. THOUGHT
FOR MOVING FORWARD- APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS AT THAT I WAS
SURPRISED HE DIDN'T SAY YOU'RE
BACK AGAIN WITH THE SAME BILL I
MEAN HOW MANY TIMES HAVE WE
LOOKED AT THIS AND TRY TO GET
AN IMPLEMENTATION STRATEGY. AND
THIS IS SERIOUS BUSINESS AND
YOU AND I KNOW THAT BECAUSE
WE'VE BEEN UP IN THE
AGRICULTURAL WORLD YOU SEE
WHAT'S HAPPENED OF THE FOREST-
I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS I
TOTALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING YOU NEED TO LOOK AT
EVERYTHING. RIGHT AND GIVE
EVERYTHING A SHOT BECAUSE WE
JUST DON'T KNOW WE'RE GOING TO
BE IN THE FUTURE SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS.
BECAUSE THEY DO MEAN A LOT TO
ME THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. THE ITEM HAS BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR SKINNER- IF YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE- IS SIMPLY ASK FOR A
VOTE. IN THIRD TIME'S A CHARM
FIRST. EXCELLENT- SECRETARY
BACK OF THIS OF. THE C. OF ITEM
NUMBER TWO ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
TEN EIGHTY SIX BYE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AGUILAR CURRY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
AND WATER ALLEN HI. ALLEN I
BATES. ALI DALI I GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I SKINNER WIENER AYE
STERN STERN HIGHWAY CASKEY. ALL
RIGHT WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN-
BUT YOU STILL HAVE THE WILL TO
GET OUT CONGRATULATIONS AND
WILL LEVELS ARE OPEN FOR THE
MEMBER SAID ON. THANK YOU GREAT
OKAY THE LONG WAITING. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARAMBULA WHO'S HERE TO
PRESENT ITEM NUMBER FIVE A. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE THIRTY
FORTY FOUR THE SUMMER YOU MAY
PRESENT WHEN YOU'RE READY. FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN. RENDON CHANGED
PROGRAM S. C. PEAS HAVE AN
ESSENTIAL IN REDUCING HIV
HEPATITIS C. AND OTHER
INFECTIOUS DISEASES IN
CALIFORNIA AB THIRTEEN FORTY
FOUR WILL PROTECT THESE VITAL
SERVICES BY PROVIDING THESE
PROGRAMS WITH AN EXEMPTION TO
SEE CORE REQUIREMENTS. WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED A RISE IN DRUG
RELATED HARMS INCLUDING
OVERDOSE DEATHS HEPATITIS C.
DIAGNOSIS RATES AND INCREASED
RATES OF POTENTIAL HIV
TRANSMISSION IN CALIFORNIA AND
THE REST OF THE UNITED STATES.
ACCESS TO STERILE SYRINGES
REDUCES HIV AND VIRAL HEPATITIS
INFECTIONS WHILE BEING SAFE
EFFECTIVE AND COST SAVING.
CALIFORNIA'S S. C. P.'S PROVIDE
A WIDE RANGE OF SERVICES IN
ADDITION TO SYRINGE ACCESS AND
DISPOSAL INCLUDING HIV AND
HEPATITIS TESTING OVERDOSE
PREVENTION TRAINING AND
REFERRALS TO DRUG TREATMENT
HOUSING AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. THESE SERVICES HAVE
HELPED TO GARNER THE TRUST IN
PEOPLE WHO WOULD NOT OTHERWISE
SEEK OUT HARM REDUCTION
STRATEGIES. BUT RECENTLY
UNEXPECTED LEGAL CHALLENGES
HAVE ARISEN DESPITE CLEAR
LANGUAGE OF THE STATUTE THAT
THIS SECTION IS TO OPERATE
NOTWITHSTANDING ANY OTHER LAW
ONE COURT IN ORANGE COUNTY HAS
INTERPRETED AS HE PEES AS
PROJECTS. SUBJECT TO THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY ACT BECAUSE THE PROGRAM
COULD NOT DEMONSTRATED THAT I
COLLECTED ALL THE SYRINGES THAT
ARE DISTRIBUTED SUBSEQUENTLY
THE PROGRAM WAS FORCED TO SHUT
DOWN ANOTHER PROGRAM IN BUTTE
COUNTY HAS BEEN FORCED TO
RESEND IT CDPH APPROVED
APPLICATION IN THE FACE OF
SIMILAR LITIGATION.
ADDITIONALLY A SIMILAR LAWSUIT
HAS BEEN FILED AGAINST AN S. E.
P. AND SANTA CRUZ IN EARLY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WE MUST BE
REMINDED THAT THERE IS AN
URGENT NEED TO EXPAND AS HE
PEES IN OUR STATE IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS OUR LOOMING OPIOID
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY. DURING
THE PANDEMIC THERE'S BEEN A
SHARP INCREASE IN OVERDOSE
DEATHS AS EVIDENCED BY THE CDC.
THE NEED FOR ACCESS TO SYRINGES
AND OTHER SERVICES PROVIDED BY
SYRINGE EXCHANGE PROGRAMS. IS
NOW GREATER THAN EVER. THESE
TYPES OF SUITS ARE AN EXAMPLE
OF HOW REQUIRING SEQUEL REVIEW
OF PUBLIC HEALTH PROGRAMS
IMPROPERLY PLACES DISEASE
PREVENTION AND ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AT ODDS. WITHOUT
IMMEDIATE LEGISLATIVE ACTION
THE PUBLIC HEALTH PREVENTION
SERVICES PROVIDED BY NCP'S
DIRECTLY AUTHORIZED BY THE CDPH
WILL BE CURTAILED AND NEW
PROGRAMS WILL BE DETERRED AT
THE PRECISE TIME WHEN THE NEED
FOR THEM IS INCREASING. AB
THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR WILL HELP
TO PROTECT CALIFORNIANS FROM A
RAPID SPREAD OF HIV HEPATITIS
AND ANY OTHER POTENTIALLY
DEADLY OR DISABLING INFECTIONS
THAT ARE SPREAD THROUGH THE
SHARING OF USED NEEDLES AND
SYRINGES. BY PROTECTING THESE
VALUABLE. COMMUNITY BASED S. C.
P.'S. I'M JOINED TODAY BY
MARICELA SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY
AT THE DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE.
YOUR DISPLAYS MERRY MERRY SILVA.
HI GOOD MORNING GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF DR ANNUAL
TEN MINUTE MERRY FALLEN ON YOUR
JOURNEY THE DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE I'M HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN FORTY
FOUR ON BEHALF OF THE CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL JOHN
POLICY ALLIANCE THE NATIONAL
HARM REDUCTION COALITION AND I
PLAN T GO AID FOUNDATION.
EIGHTY THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR X.
BALANCES BUT THE AUTHORIZATION
A THREE JUDGE PROGRAM IS NOT
SUBJECT TO THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT
PROCESS THE NEED FOR THIS BILL
OVER THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN SEVEN
YEARS AFTER INITIAL LEGISLATION
AUTHORIZING THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
CERTIFY THE PROGRAM THROUGHOUT
THE STATE WHEN A TRIAL COURT IN
ORANGE COUNTY. SOME RECHARGE IT
MOTION BUT IF YOU COULD CLAIM
AGAINST YOUR INSURANCE PROGRAMS
COULD GO FORWARD IF ONE
PRELIMINARY RULING WITH NO
FACTUAL FINDINGS CLOSE THE
ORANGE COUNTY NEEDLE EXCHANGE
PROGRAM AND LATER RESULT IN THE
CLOSURE OF CHICO DURING SERVICE
PROGRAM AS WELL WELL RECENTLY.
USING THE FIRST LETTER FROM THE
SAME THE TRYING TO BLOCK AN
ORANGE COUNTY CASE RESULTED IN
EUREKA P. ACTIVE TO OPERATING
THE MOBILE ONE AND NOW STAND
CRUZ. THE SAME. ALTHOUGH IT HAS
NEVER BEEN MANY. FUELING THE
FACT CLASSIC DURING PRO. THE
CONCERN THREE WAY. SO IT'S
IMPORTANT TO. THAT WAY. NO
INCREASED BY ORANGE PROGRAM. WE
HEARING HOW. AND AROUND COUNTRY
DONE AND THAT DURING THE WAY
BETWEEN. NOT IN. WHEN PEOPLE
ASK TO YOUR YOUR INSURANCE
PROGRAM WHEN PEOPLE WHO USE
DRUGS HAVE A SAFE PLACE TO
DISPOSE SYRINGES THE USER.
SIMPLY PUT THEIR INDEXING PARTS
THE PHONE. TO YOUR ENJOY NOT
PART OF THE PROBLEM. BY
CONTRAST FROM PEOPLE WHO USE
DRUGS DO NOT HAVE SYRINGE
EXCHANGE THE REASON SHARE
SYRINGES. MORE OFTEN AND- EARLY.
TO REQUIREMENTS GOES YOU HEALTH
PROP PROJECT. IMPROPER PLACES
DID YOU PREVENTION AND BY.
PROTECTION THAT ALL. THE CDPH
OF THE OF FOR SEVEN YEARS
WITHOUT ANY COULD LOOK. FOR THE
ONE HELD THAT IT SHOULD HAVE
THREE DOCTORS IN THE PUBLIC
HEALTH GOOD IT READ
TRANSMISSION HIV I THE INCLUDED
PEOPLE WHO USED TO AND
TREATMENT AND WE. AND FINALLY
THIS IS IMPORTANT A LOT OF TWIN
THAT ARE THEY DIE. AND OVER
DOES THAT. THE RANGE EXCHANGE
OF THEM OF THE WAY DISTRICT THE
LOCK TO PEOPLE WHO YOU DRUGS.
PROVEN TO REDUCE OVER DEATH. SO
IN THOUSAND AND THAT DOCTOR AND
ALSO AT THE HIGH WHEN YOU. HAVE
BECOME MORE FOR THE PUBLIC
HEALTH HELLO. AB MADE BY TO
THIS LEGAL CHALLENGE C. CLASS
WE'RE GRATEFUL ASSEMBLY RAN TO
CARRY BILL AND YOU SURE I. AND
HAVE TO ENSURE ANY QUESTION YOU
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT I DON'T BELIEVE.
WHO WANTS TO- TO WIN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. ON THE PHONE LINES
OPERATOR. BEIJING MEASURES
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL ME PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD AGAIN THAT'S A ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO PLEASE. WE'LL
GO TO LINE FIFTY EIGHT FIVE
EIGHT. CHEN MEMBERS MY NAME'S
ALEXANDER RODRIGUEZ WITH
EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA ACTION
REPORT A. B. ONE THREE FOUR
FOUR. THANK YOU THERE ARE NO
OTHER LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME GREAT OKAY- I NOW I DO
BELIEVE WE RISK DID RECEIVE
SOME WITH OPPOSITION FROM NINE
INDIVIDUALS AND- IS ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE HE WANTS TO
EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE BILL.
OPERATOR THANK YOU TO. THE
STATE OPPOSITION TO THE BILL IN
NAME PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AGAIN THAT'S A ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE PLEASE. THERE ARE NO
LINES IN Q. GREAT OKAY LET'S
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS CONCERNS
SENATORS US. OKAY BILLS REMOVED
FIGHTS. YES CENTER CASKEY
MISTER NORMALLY I'M NOT ON THE
SEQUEL EXEMPTION GRAVY TRAIN
EVERY TIME A BILL COMES UP HERE
BUT GIVEN THE CONCERNS HERE AND
THAT AND THAT THE HEALTH
EFFECTS I THINK IT'S A- IT'S A
GOOD MEASUREMENT HOPE IT. I
HOPE IT WORKS. YEP ALL RIGHT AS
YES SENATOR DOLLY OF SERGEANT
THERE'S GONNA. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
I WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A
CO AUTHOR AND I AM VERY PLEASED
TO SEE THAT AT LEAST ON THEIR-
DOESN'T APPEAR TO BE MAY MAYBE
THREE INDIVIDUALS BUT- I WILL
SAY THAT IN MY EFFORT TO.
CREATE THIS PROGRAM IN THE
FIRST PLACE IT TOOK ME A NUMBER
OF YEARS WITH A VERY
SIGNIFICANT OPPOSITION I THINK
THAT AS THE TESTIMONY WE HEARD.
NOT ONLY IS THIS VERY ESSENTIAL
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH BECAUSE THE-
THE BLOOD BORNE DISEASES THAT
MEANS SADLY WE- I'VE SEEN IN A
NUMBER OF OUR ENCAMPMENTS-
SEVERE OUTBREAKS OF THE HELP-
VIRUSES THAT UNFORTUNATELY CAN
BE SPREAD. THROUGH CONTAMINATED
SYRINGES AND THIS GREATLY
REDUCES THOSE OUTBREAKS AND OF
COURSE REDUCES THE WASTE NONE
OF US WANT TO SEE- RENDON A
PARKER IT YOU KNOW WHEREVER ON
THE STREET AND SEE THESE
DISCARDED SYRINGES SO I'M
REALLY GLAD YOU BROUGHT IT. AND
HAPPY TO- IF YOU'RE WILLING TO
BE A CO AUTHOR PRECIADO. THE
SENATE THIRTY DOLLARS. WELL I
GUESS I'M GONNA BE THE ONLY GUY
THAT- FIRST OF ALL I KNOW IS
STANDING UP FOR SECRET BRAND
IT'S GOOD I KNOW AND I WANT TO.
THIS IS REALLY BETWEEN AWKWARD
SPOT BECAUSE I USUALLY VOTE FOR
SEQUEL EXEMPTIONS BUT THERE IT
FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO JUST.
TAKE A MINUTE MISTER CHECK
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT WE NEED TO
GET OUT HERE BUT THIS IS
SOMETHING I'M PASSIONATE ABOUT.
SHE WAS A GOOD LAW. THE REASON
THAT WE HAVE SEEK WAS THAT. IF
YOU HAVE IMPACTS THAT'S WHY YOU
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO MITIGATE
THOSE IMPACTS. N. C. WAS BEEN
USED FOR ALL KINDS OF
MANIPULATION WHETHER IT'S- THE
ONE GRAVEL MINING COMPANY
SEQUENT ANOTHER GRAVEL MINING
COMPANY TO BUSINESSES BECAUSE
THEY DON'T WANT TO COMPETITION
WHETHER IT'S LABOR AGREEMENTS
WHETHER IT'S- PUTTING UP AN
ARENA WE WE'VE SEEN ALL KINDS
OF ABUSES OF SEQUEL BUT SEQUEL
ACTUALLY IS A REALLY GOOD LAW.
AND THE REASON WE HAVE SEQUENCE
SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE SO THAT
WE MAY MITIGATE IMPACTS. I'VE
DON'T REPRESENT ANYMORE BUT I
USED TO REPRESENT YOU COUNTY
WHERE THE LAWSUIT CAME FROM IS
ONE OF THE LAWSUITS. WHERE YOU
HAVE A DISPENSARY AND A
COLLECTION BUT IT UNFORTUNATELY
THEY- DID OR NOT ALL GETTING
COLLECTED VERY FACT VERY FEW OF
THEM ARE GETTING COLLECTED A
LOT OF THEM BEING DISPERSED.
AND IT IN A SAFE ZONE BUT THERE
ARE GETTING CORRECTED AND SO
WHAT WE HAVE WE HAVE. A PROBLEM
YOU CAN IF THERE'S A- NEEDLE
THIS BEEN USED YOU CAN GET
HEPATITIS FROM THAT NEED TO
LIVE IT'S- NOT BEEN RECYCLED
PROPERLY. THAT'S WHY THERE'S
LAWSUIT AND SO FOR ME WE'RE
GONNA JUST CARVED THIS OUT NOW
AND WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA SAY
YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THE PROCESS OF SEEK WERE. AND
THEN THERE'S A REAL GOOD REASON
THAT WE HAVE SEQUENCE BECAUSE
THERE ARE CONFLICTS HERE. SO
FOR ME IT'S LIKE I'D LOOK I
WANT TO RECYCLE ALL THE STUFF
THAT NEED TO BE SO I WANT TO
PUT IT THE RIGHT WAY STREAM.
BUT THE LAW FOR SEQUEL IS GOOD
IN THIS CASE IT'S- WAY TO
MITIGATE THOSE IMPACTS AND WHEN
THEY DON'T GET MITIGATED. WE GO
TO COURT. AND SO I CAN'T
SUPPORT THIS BECAUSE THERE'S N.
STREET IN CHICO. THEY WERE GET
THERE'S THE PARK WAS FILLED
WITH WHERE KIDS ARE GOING TO
PLAY WITH USED NEEDLES. THAT'S
IMPACTED I DON'T WANT MY CHILD
TO HAVE TO FACE AND THATS WHY
WE HAVE SECRET SO THAT YOU
MITIGATE THOSE IMPACTED OR NOT
PUT IN PLACES WHERE THEY
SHOULDN'T BE. SO I HAVE I VOTED
FOR A LOT OF SECRET EXAMS
BECAUSE I THINK TO SEEK WAS
BEEN EXAMPLE IN THIS CASE. WE
GOT TO DO THE RIGHT THING AND
MAKE SURE THAT THAT IS BEEN
MITIGATED. SO FOR THOSE REASONS
I'M NOT REAL SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY AND I. UNFORTUNATELY
IT'LL BE THE FIRST SECRET
EXEMPTION BILL IF VOTED
AGAINST. BECAUSE I LIKE TO I
THINK WE NEED TO DO SOME WORK
ON C. QUITE REALLY DO IT NEEDS
TO BE. FAIR AND IT'S NOT AND
IT'S UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE IT'S
USED IN SO MANY SITUATIONS TO
LEVERAGE SOMEBODY ELSE TO GET
SOMETHING. WE ARE VERY VERY
PUBLIC IN SAYING THAT READ THE
ORIGINAL SEQUEL LAW WAS MEANT
FOR IT WAS. A GOOD IT WAS GOOD
LAW. BUT IT'S BEEN USED IN SO
MANY BAD WAYS IN AND WE DISCUSS
DIFFERENT THAT I MEAN I DON'T
THINK THE- CHAIRMAN MAYBE IS
VOTED FOR IN THE SECRET
EXEMPTIONS IS THAT. IN THE PAST
MAYBE FEW BUT- SO FOR THOSE
REASONS I CAN'T SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY. BUT I HAVE I HAVE I
GUESS I WOULD JUST POINT A
COUPLE THINGS FIRST OF ALL
THERE ARE THERE ARE- SEVERAL- A
MITIGATION REQUIREMENTS THAT
ARE. STILL REQUIRED INTO THIS
BILL THEM THERE OUTLINED ON
PAGE FOUR. INDICATES FIVE
NOTICE PUBLIC FRUSTRATION. THE
OTHER THING JUST TO MENTION. IS
THAT NO PROJECT WILL MOVE FOR
THE SPELL WITHOUT THE FULL.
COOPERATION OF THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION. I'M AND YOU KNOW
WE ALL KNOW. THAT CITY COUNCILS
A VERY. INTERESTING PUBLIC
COMMENT AND GIVE FOLKS SOME
COMMON. RAISE WHATEVER CONCERNS
THEY HAVE THEIR- IN ADDITION TO
THE- TO THE TO THE PUBLIC
INPUT. THAT WE'VE PUT INTO THE
BILL THAT THAT ARE IN THE BILL.
THE OTHER THING I SHOULD
MENTION IS THAT. YOU UP SEE
RIGHT. THERE THERE'S A THERE'S
A PROBLEM WITH WITH. YOUR
NEEDLE LITTER. IF ANYTHING KIND
OF BUILDING PINE CENTER SKINNER
COMMENTS. ASIF SITE THAT IS
ACTUALLY PROPERLY MANAGED IS
ACTUALLY FAR LESS LIKELY TO
RESULT IN. DANGEROUS I NEED A
LETTER AND THEN OF AN
UNREGULATED. FREE FOR ALL WHICH
IS WHAT WE HAVE OUT ON OUR
STREETS RIGHT NOW SO. THAT'S
WHY I'M SUPPORTING THE BILL- I
BETTER BUT BUT YEAH YOU'RE
YOU'RE YOUR YOUR POINT ARE WELL
TAKEN CERTAINLY KNOW I THIS IS
A NAME. THIS IS LIKE NOBODY
WISHES WE WERE IN A SITUATION
WHERE EVEN THIS WAS EVEN A
THING RIGHT I MEAN HOW TERRIBLE
IS IT THAT WE'RE SITTING HERE
HAVING TO- FIGURE OUT HOW TO
ACCOMMODATE. AND THE REALITY OF
THIS. OUT OF CONTROL DRUG USE
THAT EXIST. IN OUR STREETS. AND
THAT'S A WHOLE NOTHER BROAD
ISSUE THAT WE ALL NEED TO WORK
TOGETHER ON SO THAT WE NEVER
NEED TO HAVE THIS KIND OF.
THESE KINDS OF SITES. ANY OUT-
NOT SEEING ANY ADDITIONAL
THOUGHTS OR COMMENTS IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER SKINNER- IF YOU
HAVE ANY. YOUR RESPONSE OR IF
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THE SONG
EVER. WE WELCOME THAT. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS FOR THE
CONVERSATION AS WELL AS FOR
SOME OF THE DISAGREEMENTS THAT
WE MATH. I'M HAPPY TO SHARE
THAT THIS IS THE FIRST SEQUEL
EXEMPTION I BELIEVE I HAVE EVER
CARRIED WHILE IN OFFICE. AND TO
BELIEVE IT WAS NECESSARY FOR US
TO ADDRESS AN ISSUE THAT WAS
OCCURRING RIGHT NOW. HI I WOULD
LIKE TO IF I COULD SENATOR
ADDRESS YOUR ISSUE WHICH WAS
THAT SEEK WELL WHICH IS TO BE
BROUGHT IN IF THERE ARE
IMPACTS. AND WHAT THE RESEARCH
IS SHOWING US IS THAT THERE ARE
LESS IMPACTS LESS SYRINGES WHEN
THE SYRINGE EXCHANGE PROGRAMS
ARE IN COMMUNITIES. HAPPY TO
PROVIDE THAT RESEARCH THAT WE
HAVE HERE IN CALIFORNIA AS WELL
AS HAS BEEN DONE AROUND THE
UNITED STATES BUT IT'S BEEN
FAIRLY WELL STUDIED- AND
BELIEVE IT'S QUITE CONVINCING-
FOR THE- WHAT YOU'RE
REFERENCING REGARDING IMPACTS.
I WOULD FOLLOW UP THAT THERE IS
AN APPROPRIATE AVENUE FOR THEM
TO LITIGATE IF THEY ALL HAVE
CONCERNS AND THAT IS A NUISANCE
PROVISION. THAT I THINK IS
CONTINUING TO WORK THROUGH THE
COURTS AND SO EVEN IF WE ARE TO
EXEMPT- S. C. P.'S FROM SEQUOIA
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE LOCALS TO
CONTINUE TO ASK QUESTIONS AND-
AT PURSUE THAT AVENUE. WITH
THAT I WILL THANK VERY MUCH
THIS COMMITTEE AND. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FROM MY BOOK.
THANK YOU FOR THIS. SUMMER BY
CENTERS- ACCOMPLISHED. I THE
NUMBER FIVE- AB THIRTEEN FORTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER ARAMBULA
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ALAN HI ALAN I'D BE. NO BATES
NOTE DOLLY ALI NO GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I SKINNER SKINNER AYE
STERN STERN AYE WIECKOWSKI
MAKOWSKI I FIVE TWO. PART CAN
WE- JUST THAT THANK YOU
GRADUATIONS LET'S LET'S- LET'S
HEAR OF MOTION FOR EXECUTIVES
MOVE BY I CENTER AND SALAS-
BECAUSE ALMOST ALL AROUND. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ITEM NUMBER
SIX. ALLEN HI WHEN I BATES HI
AS I. DALI DALI I GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I SKINNER SKINNER AYE
STERN STERN I LIKE HOW SCHEME
LIKE BECAUSE HE I. EIGHT THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS APPROVED
LET'S NOW GO BACK THROUGH THE
ROLE SO AS TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO
ADD ON LET'S START WITH ITEM
NUMBER ONE THE C. BEFORE
SEVENTY BY TAKING. ARE THE
NUMBER ONE EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. THE CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE TWO ZERO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING HI. BATES NOT BUILDING.
BATES NOT VOTING DALI. DALI
KNOWN STERN. AYE STERN AYE AYE
CASCADE AYE MAKOWSKI AYE. OKAY
THE BILLS OUT LET'S NOW GO TO
ITEM TO THIS IS AB TEN EIGHTY
SIX BY YEAH CURRY. I THE NUMBER
TWO AB TEN EIGHTY SIX BYE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARGUE ARE
CURRY. THE MOTION IS DUE
PROCESS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
AND WATER. OUT CHAIRS BUILDING
HI. OF BEATS BY. BATES I OF AYE
CASKEY AYE. MCCARTY AYE SEVEN
ZERO ALRIGHT IT'S OUT SEVEN
ZERO COULD I AM THREES AB
ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN BY FRIEDMAN.
I THE NUMBER THREE AB ELEVEN
FORTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT BE RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR TO ONE
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I BATES
NO. BATES KNOWS STERN. AYE
STERN AYE IT'S FIVE TWO TWO
OKAY FIVE TWO TWO THAT IS OUT
WAS GOOD ITEM FOR THIS IS AB
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX BY CORREA. I
REMEMBER FOR AB TWELVE SEVENTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE TWO ONE
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING HI BATES
NO. BATES NO. OKAY THAT'S FIVE
INTO THAT BILLS OUT LET'S NOW
GO TO ITEM FIVE AB THIRTEEN
FORTY FOUR BY AROUND ALIVE. IS
THAT ARE GOING ON THAT GOT
EVERYONE THERE IS ON THAT IT
WAS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR TO.
YEP GREAT THAT MEANS WE ARE
DONE THANK YOU MEMBERS WE WILL
BE BACK NEXT WEEK FOR MORE
EXCITEMENT- BUT UNTIL THEN THIS
HEARING IS ADJOURNED. READ THE
STUFF ON THE BERMAN BILL AND
THEN. FOR YOUR.